[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
first diploma
your first job in a big company
first date the first expensive things
you bought when you got your first
paycheck and your first Investments with
freedom broker Freedom broker look at
your favorite brands from A New
Perspective
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome this is the
final day of this year's weld Blitz
championships here live coverage on
chess.com I'm Lawrence Trent I'm with
the one and only the legend the the the
myth from Brighton
the multi-time British champion
the Olympic gold medalist
and Slick dancer himself Grandmaster
David Howe David lovely to be here with
you to cover this final day
uh it's a pleasure Lawrence it's been a
fun few days
um also how am I going to live up to
that uh billing now thank you for the
kind words but uh that's true yeah
you've got a lot of Rhythm people might
not know it but people that have seen
you in action know you can move those
hips
David today
what a day we've got in store
exactly it's a huge day there's a world
title on the line there's plenty of cash
on the line as well huge prizes we'll
talk about what's at stake
um in a moment we see uh the open
section 60
000 for first prize some huge names
gunning for that of course and in the
women's section 40
000 uh we have had one huge day of Blitz
chess one Marathon day yesterday with 12
games in the uh open section and nine
rounds in the women's section today
Lawrence more action guaranteed some as
we as mentioned some uh Giants of Chess
and legends of World Chess fighting it
out duking it out uh yeah yeah on one of
the final days of 2022
absolutely and uh as mentioned yesterday
and even as mentioned at the beginning
of the uh rapid championships
this is no ordinary Blitz tournament
it's the world Blitz championships and
it has it is held with extremely high
regard and high esteem by the world's
best players uh this is a title that is
desperately uh desired by a lot of
players in this field
especially the man uh leading the open
we're going to come to that let's look
at the women's section first
because
it's also an interesting Tournament of
course
um
it's a bit more tightly packed
but let's have a look at that table we
have Paulina shuvalova and Valentina
gunina leading the pack so far David
what have your impressions been
of these two players and perhaps some of
the players just in behind them
yeah uh all of these players at the top
of the table in the top ten there
they're banging Form shout out to shovel
over who has been leading for much of
the blitz she did lose a game towards
the end of yesterday but she bounced
back ended the day on a high and she's
going to be full of confidence gunina
form player a very streaky player as you
mentioned uh yesterday Lawrence she's
capable of going on massive winning
rounds but also uh lacks a bit of
consistency she was leading the rapid
fell back a bit there so can those two
take the heat they are chased by tanzong
Yi the world rapid Champion we've seen
her in blistering form Goya and the
chess Queen herself kostenyuk I mean
those are huge names on the women's
scene they're capable of anything it's
it's not going to be easy and these are
some of the pairings already we see
gunana having to hold off because
stenyuk if she wants to maintain her
lead monster Clash there on board one
guy against shovel over equally
important for Russians on the top two
boards and tanzong Yi will be aiming to
beat sagitte with white as you mentioned
Lawrence
um so many big names it's all about
whether they can hold their nerves
there's going to be eight rounds in the
women's section so still plenty of
action and um who can stay the course
that's the big question
yep ten tons of games left uh way too
early to call a winner with it so
tightly packed as I mentioned I'm a big
fan of Valentina gunina I feel like it's
been a long time since she's had a real
run at the tournament at a rough few
years
um you know a fantastic player and when
she's on form
she showed fantastic form yesterday but
she's got a lot more work to do if she's
gonna really pull this one out the bag
with so many great players around her be
fun to see that let's have a look at the
situation in the open section and Hikaru
Nakamura he couldn't really ask for much
more after day one 10 out of 12 points
never in trouble
converted when you needed to convert
held off some of the big guns when he
needed to do that didn't have a single
prob well he he went for a very Jewish
line against Magnus Carlsen but this in
was a very pragmatic decent approach and
as a result he leads the field by a
whole point
with uh
what is it nine rounds to go
but it's nine rounds and a lot can
happen there's a pack of wolves just
behind him Geary having a great
tournament Magnus having a decent
tournament actually very lucky in my
opinion to be on that score should have
lost against
look shaky in some other spots as well I
think you should be very happy to be on
nine points Daniel duboff has shown uh
moments of Brilliance as he always does
uh very impressive Daniel Duval and what
about this hike motor Rosie and the
young Armenian Grandmaster lit
specialist also up there Rickard Rapport
as well making a late little Dash to get
to nine points those five players hot on
the heels of Hikaru Nakamura and then of
course we have a mammoth amount of
players on eight and a half points
shimanov saidwani matlakov jumsa and
yeah napometri
by no means a push over
great little player from India
but an apology might do a little late
burst if he can get off to a win against
sagwani today he'll be right in the mix
and he is of course capable of causing
upsets against
the big guys
a few uh not other big names on eight
points they are way off the lead though
two points off the lead but
as David mentioned everything about this
blitz tournament is streaks and momentum
that that is the key if you manage to
put two three wins together
uh all of a sudden you could be back in
the mix and
wow what a what a first first round of
today round 13 we have Carlson
martirosian Rapport nakumura David I I I
think this is a dream pairing for Magnus
to be brutally honest coming starting
today he gets the white pieces against a
much a weaker player on paper it's going
to be a a very sort of overwhelming uh
spot for matarosian but for me game of
the round has to be Rapport Nakamura
thoughts on this one
yep it's a huge game we'll talk more
about the pairings uh as as the games go
we are actually about to start we see
Hikaru Nakamura uh at the board right
now he's been sitting there for almost
10 minutes you mentioned Lawrence a huge
game he needs to start day two of the
blitz tournament well he wants his
second world title of 2022 Hikaru
Nakamura after winning the for sure
random World Championship a couple of
months ago and yeah he starts with black
he is up against that
firebrandt Rapport who can't beat anyone
on his day reports is very very
ambitious usually so uh Hikaru will want
to at least survive this first game on
Skate remember Hikaru Nakamura he's
unbeaten in 25 games in Kazakhstan over
the rapid and Blitz sections impressive
stuff if Nakamura can avoid defeat by
the end of the day he's surely going to
get that that Crown here we see board
one another question will Magnus Carlsen
turn up on time yesterday we nearly saw
him default the first game of the day
arriving two and a half minutes late and
basically playing a bullet game with 30
seconds on his clock and
um Nakamura there he was a frown off to
the audience as I think we do see
Richard report arriving but uh here's
the playing call we'll get into the
thick of the action soon don't write off
Daniel duboff Anish giri on board three
facing off against each other dubov
checkmated giri a few days ago uh in the
world rapid champion ship and both of
those two they'll need to start winning
what a story it would be Lawrence you
mentioned the other name nepomniacci he
lost three games in a row earlier in the
tournament but he's back in the thick of
things uh just behind the uh chasing
pack uh here we see Magnus Carson has
indeed arrived so uh no heart attack for
his fans and uh I think we'll see the
first moves any moment now was uh very
fast and very very Furious yesterday uh
once we got to know the first few games
we saw the players start the days with
winning streaks Loris do you think we'll
see the game uh the same again
um I you know I think you'd be mad not
to go for a Carlson win after being able
to rest reset white pieces White against
multi-rosion I just don't think any
other prediction is is reasonable I
think the more difficult pairing to
to really uh evaluate is this one raffle
against Nakamura
this is really a three result game for
me I mean a lot of it depends on on
Rapport uh Hikaru is in absolutely no
need to go nuts he's got a point
advantage over the field this is not a
must win scenario for Hikaru I think if
you're Hikaru it's just really important
not to lose get into some kind of steady
rhythm
um and if you get presented a chance
take it uh so I expect a very uh High
sort of uh
um level of risk mitigation from Hikaru
but if you're somebody like Rapport at
the point behind you can't just make a
bunch of draws and and hope that that's
going to be enough to keep you close
because a lot of the guys behind you are
going to start winning and overtaking
you
for example if you're a rapport you draw
now you draw the next round and you draw
the one after that suddenly you're way
off the pace and there's just not enough
rounds so you're white I think you've
got to go for it here if you're a
rapport I want to see something
uncompromising I'm going to see
something a bit more let's say
old school Rapport it's a Blitz game mix
it up
um and see how you do
note how also Hikaru is wearing the same
shirt as yesterday talking about you
know I was talking about this before
chess player in there chess players and
their uh
um what's it called their uh
um Superstition superstitions thank you
Hikaru had a great day yesterday wearing
the same shirt
is clearly superstitious
uh
not the first chess player to do
something like this you know chess
players aren't known for doing their
laundry during tournaments and yeah why
change a winning recipe and uh Hikaru
with his lucky shirt we see the
ceremonial first move made by some local
dignitaries uh on the Magnus Carlson
board one B4 I don't think Magnus is
going to play that move it is the
orangutan opening uh Magnus has played
it before however so we'll see if that
weird wacky move is played on move one
uh we should mention Magnus is on a
drawing streak he's drawn five games in
a row so he really needs to up the
energy you mentioned there Lawrence you
can't just uh take your foot off the gas
you can't get stuck in a rut as the uh
move that is made on the top Board of
the women's section and uh yeah Hikaru
Nakamura has a lot of respect for a
report of course but reports on board
one of the uh or one of the top seats on
the open he is not known for being a
blitz specialist he barely plays online
I very rarely see him playing on
chess.com for example he's more known
for longer time controls and he's
indicating that he wants to play one E4
on move one does that mean Lawrence that
Magnus indicated one D4 to his game
what a turn up for the books that would
be well I mean I would be
pretty shocked if he does decide to play
that movie because even that I think I
think he would prefer 1a4 over 1b4 to be
brutally honest I mean B4 is
uh maybe it's an okay opening but it's
I mean for years I I thought there's
been some pretty good antidotes to
playing against 1v4
so I'm very curious but here we go
indeed go for E4
yeah we have started it's the final day
of the world Blitz Championship report
opens with the Roy Lopez the Spanish
these two have played each other plenty
of times before over the board oh no the
fact that Rapport is thinking after the
Berlin that is a bad sign we have seen
quick draws between these two in the
past Lawrence I was going to say it
before the game this is a well-known
drawing line report play for the win
what are you doing here off the board we
see a set of Trades this is a well-known
draw and anti-climax Lawrence a quick
handshake it's over in a blink that was
a 30 second game at most and good result
for Hikaru you'd have to say with black
against a strong player but why report
why not take your opportunity with white
against the leader you really want he
really needed the win there as you said
beforehand
as well
I mean shock actually to be honest you
you know I understand there's a lot of
money up for grabs but we're way way uh
too far away from from thinking about
the the money prizes to make a draw like
that I'm you know it's a great result
for Karu because he's got black he
maintains his his lead he's effectively
had a free game he can go and rest
but uh no I think this is a a really
poor decision from rapport
the only justification is that he's he's
not feeling well or there's something
that's happened but to just willingly
make a draw
first round of the day not even try and
press with white in a Blitz game come on
what's this and the the chest gods do
tend to punish those who take quick
draws with white so we'll see how
Rapport gets on meanwhile let's focus on
Magnus Carlson he started the game with
one B3 something he's done a lot out
there in Kazakhstan over the last few
days and matarossian has come prepared
look at the clocks Festival Magnus is
one minute down on the clock he didn't
arrive late this time but he's already
struggling there in terms of position it
looks very balanced it looks like a
successful opening for MATA rosian as
black symmetrical Pawn structure almost
lots of pieces coming off the board it
doesn't look great for Magnus Carson
you've got to say it looks like somehow
there's just no initiative everything's
just getting traded off the knights have
all disappeared from the board it's
purely a bishop uh type of position
right now with a blocked center it's
hard to imagine anything too dramatic
happening there's one open file on the
position that will be the e-file lots of
Rooks will get traded off there later
Lawrence can we see Magnus fall to a
sixth draw in a row that would be
Hammer blow to his chances surely as he
aims to try and catch up with Nakamura
he will have had one eye on the action
as well he will know Nakamura finished
with a quick draw this is his
opportunity but he it doesn't look great
I'm going to say that now well I mean
how do you you know uh I I didn't I
understood Magnus playing B3 for the day
maybe two but when you give your
opponent a whole night to prepare
and find something
I think this is actually a very poor
opening Choice especially because I'll
move forward if we go to move forward
Magnus played the unorthodox Knight of
three here the main line is to go Bishop
E5
but when you go Knight F3
which is what he has done against Marty
rosian matarosian can literally Force
the action and that's what he did
because after E4 you're pretty much
forced to go 94 95 is also a move but he
would have calculated uh we've done some
work on that and after 94 Bishop C5
he's simply done enough work here
um
20 minutes is sufficient to get a decent
position and if we look at the game
uh this is this is just zero for for
Magnus I mean here's Magnus and he can
conjure things up and he can make
miracles happen
but uh
but I mean what can we say about the
position
it is uh equal material
form structures equal minor pieces are
equal
um
the bar does tend to like white though
yeah the bar like in white I think
liking what has happened over the last
couple of moves I'm a bit confused about
why Mata rosian decided not to try and
trade light squared Bishops a few moves
ago if black can exchange one final set
of pieces then the pressure will all
dissipate and uh equality will ensue
okay Bishop A3 by Magnus there is a
threat on the board white wants to take
that black Rook on f8 uh Queen takes f8
would win the exchange so suddenly
matarosian is realizing there is some
pressure this might be the Magnus effect
not let's not write him off too soon
um not the most inspiring opening by
white of course should be level I think
in a classical game we would say this is
just gonna fizzle out but it is Blitz
and uh now matarosian for the first time
lower on the clock than Magnus under one
minute it feels like the nerves are
kicking in there's always pressure when
you play Magnus castle and there are
always tricks on the board always
pitfalls to avoid and matarazzi I'm
playing very hesitantly there he swaps a
pair of Rooks but now look at Magnus
he's pushing his a pawn is he about to
win a pawn Lawrence
it feels like Monte rosian has just
completely lost control it's still
complicated White's Queen has the option
of taking a Pawn on B7 Magnus snaps that
pawn off but there will be consequences
and uh at least he's imbalanced things
Magnus Carson at least for the first
time in the game the pawn structure is
no longer fully symmetrical and the
White Queen very active well it's got a
nice home for the dark Square Bishop too
this one is turning in White's favor
look at the board look at the clock
but can he finish it off
feels like from a completely equal
position he has been outplaying his
opponent and uh yeah yeah it's something
good for white now something went wrong
for Marta Rosie and around move 15 this
queen before a moment think Queen V8 by
Mata Rosen if we just go back here
um he could have actually gone Bishop C7
immediately I believe and the point is
if you take on B7 uh you can now play
Queen D6 protecting the bishop
threatening mate and if mate is
protected let's say with a move like G3
suddenly you've got the move Rook B8 and
after Queen A6 rugby six and the queen
is almost trapped the queen has to come
here and then you run into moves like
Rook takes B3 with the un uh discovered
attack on the queen so that was a key
key thing to do now white is better for
sure uh how critical it is I'm not
entirely sure but he's only got 14
seconds this is going to be a tough
asking for multi-rosium but very very
good Blitz player let's see if he
manages to
hold here but it's looking like he's
creating more weaknesses I I don't like
his chances now
yep he's really changed the pawn
structure suddenly black is facing some
huge threats we saw in the video there
the black queen came into the center it
was immediately kicked back by White's
Rook motorizing has just lost two Tempe
two very important moves and Magnus is
turning the screen out creating threats
on every move momentum all in his favor
Magnus I think has just won a pawn
according to the video feed there that
we do have matarasian it's just
impossible to play with 10 seconds very
good Blitz player but Queen takes C8
beautiful tactic if the black Bishop
recaptured the White Queen then Black's
Queen also falls white Windsor rook in
the process Magnus finishing off in
style but yeah it just fell apart he
spent too long on the clock and like you
said as he pointed out there Lawrence
one slip is all it takes against Magnus
and uh important win he's only half a
point behind Hikaru now as the chase
continues and uh let's try and see if
there are other games going on uh well I
think he's magic there
just to point out duboff Geary was also
a draw which uh is good news for Magnus
as well but I think we should go to the
game round except one against an apology
um so wani with uh the it looks around
Levi looks very very
unbalanced to me I mean I'm looking at
this position I have absolutely no idea
of what's going on
um just could go out anyway here I I
just uh now we have a rook ending which
also looks very unclear to me
who would you take it black can
potentially win the C Pawn but then
white king is active
yeah it's a very complicated Lawrence I
think I would take white but uh hell now
that pawn has reached E2 I'm not sure uh
it's the same case anymore uh we had a
lot of Pawns there I did look like
Napoleon she was aiming for the win wow
okay do we have board one of the women's
section still in place it looks like we
have cameras on them now Alexandra
kostenic as black she is checking that
white king it's pawned down though for
her so she needs to force a Perpetual
check
yeah it's definitely white with all the
winning chances here gunino you can see
the nerves on her face uh see the
tension what a game this is if she wins
with white she's got to be the favorite
now uh to take it home really nice move
there by White Knight F3 look at that
black queen caged in the corner no more
checks Gotta Lose time re-routing her
and white is going to pick up more pawns
White's turn to start checking uh we see
a bunch of moves played there white is
three pawns up this must be winning
Lawrence those two white points gonna
run through to promote
yeah they are not nothing much that
Alexandra can do here she has to pray
for a night Fork night D6 Knight to E4
something like that she needs a she
needs an absolute uh meltdown here by
gunina but just pin the night yeah
queenie6 G7 lovely get that Queen away
from all the forking squares and this is
G7 there's no checks you're gonna Queen
the pawn I think that's it I think yeah
and Alexander Christine resigns
win
mm-hmm yeah she kept control when it
mattered she her nerves held strong uh
she really played well in that thing
that game gunina great technique and it
looks like she will be in the lead I
don't know if we have a result on uh
board two of the women's section
Lawrence and uh here you see Mama jarov
uh as white we were checking on those
results a bit later mama jarov needs to
win to catch up with that chasing pack
banging the clock there
does look like a completely equal end
game and uh actually it's a completely
equal maybe black has the better chances
centralized Queen nice compact Pawn
structure this one should be a draw with
best play too many checks on the board
look how quickly they're playing five
seconds for black
it does look like this one should fizzle
out Mama jar of his winning chances uh
will be frustrated most like most likely
it looks like the live board as well
black is a pawn up if I'm not counting
wrongly here bullying white with the
threat of the queen exchange no no it's
it's important I think it's black oh no
sorry I think Lawrence black is a pawn
up I beg your partner that black is a
porno there has been a change
oh I were fighting for his life in that
case and this won't be a great result
for him either way uh Mama jaros
opponent is a very strong young
International master from Uzbekistan
Madame rated what is it 400 points below
shakuria exactly 400 points lower rated
but he's the one turning the screw
putting his pressure on oh I'm Queen
he's gonna win the second pawn and and
this is bad news for Shaq now this H1 is
going to run this could be a huge upset
you just got to go H4 Queen G3 check
that's it
yeah straightforward Victory now nothing
for Shaq to do Checkmate is coming all
pawns are dropping more importantly
horns
just H3
now H3 surely
you can push H3 now there are no
stalemates white has a B Pawn you don't
have to worry about stalemate
okay Queen E7 Saves the Day clever move
Black's King now safe from any checks
marching up the board
he's walking in with his King he wants
to go see yeah yeah he's getting in no
matter what
beautiful technique here by black
all you need to do is find a safe Square
for that black king now push the F1 F4
okay give us a few more checks will his
nurse hold Lawrence
no King G3 King G3 and F4
mm-hmm
now
Queen B3
Queen oh Queen
moose
can he find a safe hiding place you can
see the nerves though visibly five
seconds left he's gotta choose a new
Square now and right upon advancing
suddenly Lawrence is so easy it's
definitely
that must still be winning but you have
to choose the right checks
I don't think he's going to find it I
think he's panicking here oh it's
something behind him I like that because
if the queen now tries to Aid that porn
home you can play King G3 and win this
is a great great move by the youngster
four seconds now for Shaq
Gotta Move he's got to move
oh he's got he's got to build a few more
seconds
uh okay he gives a check there were some
stalemating ideas in the position here
you've got to be really careful where
you put looking
okay yeah now he's threatening the pawn
this is great yeah because now you can't
protect the pawn and prevent mate well
done
well done tonight
I'm still not so sure there are some
checks Queen C5 check Queen G3 you gotta
okay he does play Queen G3 and check
please forgot about the clock
too slow in the under he uh yeah just as
we saw yesterday with Anish Geary With
You Yankee and a few other players the
clock tractor
water results for the young player there
yeah congrats to Madame very uh big
upset there
yeah huge upset
looks as though look at the playing ball
now yeah it looks as though the majority
of the games are
coming to a close at least most of them
let's have a look at the
he results Magnus Carlson
are we Lawrence we still have okay we
still have more games sorry to interrupt
the uh Eric icy it looks like in action
against uh Turkish player vahap sanal we
saw a huge crowd in the playing Hall
including Fabiano caruana it's Rook vs
Knight theoretical draw well-known draw
and oh we see the handshake just as
black blund is The Rook luckily a rook
blunder not terminal uh a knight on its
own can't give checkmates so yeah
disappointing draw for both of them they
started behind their expectations
perhaps Eric Icy not living up to his
hopes for the tournament so as you
mentioned earlier Lawrence looks like
most of the results are in now most of
the games have finished
in DD
looks as though
they have let's go through the the key
results in the open Magnus Carlson with
that crucial win against Marta rosian a
disappointing anticlimactic draw in
Rapport versus Nakamura
dubov Gary was also a draw
matlakov playing against artemia big win
for our Timmy have with the black pieces
there that puts him back in the mix and
we said napomnishi if he managed to beat
savwani he also is right back in it he's
now won seven and a half out he's got
seven and a half out of his last eight
he's on nine and a half joining the
likes of uh Rapport dubov Theory
of Musa was a draw Duda beat shimanov
and then draken beats lazovic he meaning
they get to nine Kmart is also online so
a bunch a short uh distance behind but
uh really it's still all about those top
view guys Hikaru on Ten and a half
Magnus just half a point behind now on
Ten and then the group of players on
nine and a half that's going to be very
interesting and in the women's section
massive massive massive win for gunina
beating castinia massive win for
shuvalova beating
and tanjong ji being Nana's agnity only
half a point behind David
she is still very much on for the double
yep that would be a huge result for the
Chinese player if she's able to catch up
but those two leaders still ahead of the
pack and uh on that note I think we will
check in more on the standings in a
moment we'll check in on those parents
for the next round as well crucial games
ahead but uh in the meantime let's take
a break for a couple of minutes let's
refresh and see you all soon
life is full of exciting events but it
is our first impressions that we
remember best your first diploma
[Applause]
your first job in a big company
Unforgettable emotions from the first
date the first expensive things you
bought when you got your first paycheck
and your first Investments with freedom
broker Freedom broker look at your
favorite brands from A New Perspective
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
's coverage of the feed 8 World Blitz
chess championships It's the final day
we've just seen round number 13 of 21 in
the open section and we've just seen
around 10 of
uh what is it night uh 17 in the women's
section
uh an important round first round of the
day uh and uh well David not so
impressed by rapport's
uh decision but uh Magnus Carlsen will
certainly be happy with the way things
went in that first round
uh yes as you say Lawrence some huge
developments in that first round on the
board and on the standings uh as you
mentioned Nakamura did get that quick
draw against report report with the
white pieces taking a very negative
decision to force a draw in the opening
that does mean that the Gap has narrowed
Nakamura only has half a point lead over
Magnus Carlson who did profit and uh did
coaster victory in the end there against
Mata rosian
now all on nine and a half they are in
the chasing pack I think we will check
out the pairings in a moment but we'll
see that rapport's reward for his Quick
Draw is black against Magnus Carlson uh
that's gonna be a tough one but fair
play to napomishi especially we
mentioned earlier in the tournament I
think between rounds three and five he
lost three games in a row now he is only
one point off the lead so Napoleon
actually that there we see momentum is
on his side watch out for him to
continue to Surge through the pack and
uh here we see the rest of the top
players top performers in the world
Blitz championships still some big names
who could play the spoiler role who
could still catch up feasibly including
their we see the likes of Fabiano
caruana and um some surprise names as
well some very young players doing a job
uh impressing out there in Kazakhstan
let's check out those match-ups Lawrence
it is Carlson against report on board
one as we mentioned this is what happens
when you mess with the chess guards when
you take quick draws you get black
against the world number one oh that is
going to be an uphill struggle and
napoleonishi gets his shot at the leader
the punishi Nakamura another monster
Clash there predictions Lawrence I've
got to ask
well uh predictions are uh are are in
line with the what the chess Gods want I
think uh unfortunately for record
rapport
um
this is a terrible spot
um
and you're facing a very hungry Magnus
Carlsen
and unfortunately for rapport
I don't feel the hunger uh when you make
a quick draw like that against Hikaru
sure Hikaru is a great Blitz player sure
it's the first round
you're not going to get that chance
against Magnus Carlson Magnus
understands he's got what he's been
given the double white which is already
unbelievable for him
so he can really press
uh and
yeah I don't like rapport's chances at
all
um
so very bullish on on Magnus
and as for Hikaru
well what do you think about this one
David what do you think he's got white
now
yeah
um Hikaru has black uh oh he has black I
beg your opponent I thought he had white
as well sorry he has yeah so we see him
arriving early
yeah very early yet again Hikaru in his
lucky shirt uh he's got a double black
which means he might well get a double
white later in the tournament so for
Hikaru drawing this one is not
necessarily a bad result he'll still at
least be in the joint lead but it's all
about momentum as we highlighted at the
beginning of the show and momentum wise
you don't want to slow down too much we
saw Carlson as soon as he started
drawing yesterday got both down five
draws in a row and uh Nakamura will want
to get back to winning ways but he's
against the informed player at the
moment Jan napomnishi
future world championship Challenger in
the classical format and Jan he has
scored as you mentioned I think seven
and a half out of his last eight games
that is a huge streak very impressive
run and niponishi is especially
dangerous with the white pieces his
opening repertoire through preparation
for the world championship is uh now
bulletproof almost the problem is she
often getting huge advantages
significant advantages uh with white
even against the top guys in the world
so this one is not going to be an easy
pairing I think we'll be focusing a lot
of our attention here to see whether the
leader can maintain uh his place uh in
the playing Hall meanwhile a lot of the
players just still hanging out we see
Joe bother there having a laugh with
feathersev and um yeah those two
climbing the table fed us there are also
doing very well uh artemiev who's only
one point back
we see there in picture
uh very distinctive look Lawrence
uh we'll be focusing on the top two
boards at least but things are opening
up we mentioned that in the women's
section it was a very uh kind of tight
pack at the top of the table and now in
the open section very much the same
let's check out those standings for the
women Lawrence yeah let's do that
because what we have is we have gunina
and shuvalova on eight and a half both
of these uh ladies showing tremendous
form uh remember that's eight and a half
out of ten
uh unbelievable score but tanjongi we
cannot sleep on her because she has been
uh tremendous throughout she has just
not really shown any dip in form either
in the Rapid or in the Blitz
well within striking range and I expect
tanjong Ji to cause real problems to
these two a bit of a gap after that a
whole point where we see a massive group
of players on seven points including
pbsara whatever
last year's champion
uh for uh for uh it was rapid wasn't it
that she won not the blue it was the I
know she won the blitz I beg your pardon
she won the Blitz and came second in the
rapid excuse me so and she has been
uploaded all the way because Goodyear
has played pretty much everybody around
the top boards so she plays good enough
massive massive game for us wherever if
she manages to win this
it blows open things and people are
going to be hoping that Lele
talented experienced Jordan uh Grandma
so she's going to be able to hold off
Sugarloaf not so Keen
on uh yavakash really with black in that
spot but ask Forever on her day in her
moment she can do anything that's going
to be a really interesting game to keep
an eye on
yup we will keep an eye on all of those
results as they trickle in from the
women's section of course but I think
we're going to have to focus on
janaponishi against Hikaru Nakamura I
don't think we'll see a quick draw in
this game yanduponishi will not want to
end his uh hot streak with a timid draw
he's gonna go at Hikaru he's gonna be
taking risks especially with the white
pieces there we see the chess bras I'm
on Hamilton Eric Hansen joined by
ariantari sharing a laugh in the middle
of the playing pool I don't know how
they always seem to find themselves on
the camera I don't know if it's
coincidence but there's chess for us
looking very relaxed and Hikaru Nakamura
waiting for the games to start I like
the fact that Hikaru is sitting at the
board early I think it's good in terms
of getting in the right mindset he wants
to still stay focused as much as
possible he knows he's got Magnus
breathing down his neck
but uphill struggle potentially against
napoleonishi at least in the early
stages of the game will hikaru's solid
black opening repertoire hold up Hikaru
is very solid with black we've got to
say he's much more ambitious with white
he's happy to Freestyle a bit more with
the white pieces uh Jan I'm expecting
him to use that world championship
opening repertoire 1e4 just go very
direct very uh testing uh in terms of
the opening phase but
hey Lawrence I I do believe that Magnus
is a big favorite against Rapport who we
see walking in the background there
if Magnus does get that win the second
win of the day surely Hikaru is going to
start feeling nervous
Lawrence I'm not sure I can hear you
right now
but uh meanwhile excuse me in the
playing Hall
let me do that again sorry I was just
about to say would be a catastrophe for
Hikaru if Magnus managed to catch him up
just within two games it's not what he
wanted at all uh he's relying on some of
the other guys to actually stand up but
uh you know he'll be looking at the
pairing and not feeling overly excited
about
um
uh rapport with the black pieces
uh we'll see can can Magnus
uh finally you know fall at a hurdle is
it somebody like Richard Rapport is he
the sort of guy to cause the upset on
one hand he is right on one hand this is
the guy that can
magic his his way and do uh do the
unexpected
um
I personally don't believe he has the
hunger that Magnus has though and that's
my problem
he has beaten Magnus before report I
remember a very nice gaming classical
chess where he took down Magnus a few
years back in vikanzai but on the whole
Magnus has the upper hand in their
head-to-head scores and uh as we
mentioned rapport with black
he's a good player of course he's one of
the world's top he's capable of anything
but Magnus with white you've got to back
him and uh will Rapport be punished for
taking that quick draw you've got to say
taking a quick draw in the first game of
the day means you're not fully warmed up
yet either Magnus is clearly uh feeling
warmed up after his very very uh kind of
sharp finish against matarosian in the
first game of the day here we see the
handshake so will a fresh Magnus be able
to take down a rapport who hasn't really
played too much chess so far today we
will focus I think Lawrence on the nepo
against Naco Clash on the second board
remember Magnus is fixed on board one
but uh [ __ ] the leader right now
yep absolutely I I think nepo knackers
is a great great game to to focus on
um obviously
uh massive massive swap from the
publisher as well if the publishy uh it
manages to win this
particular game okay
that suddenly throws a whole new Dynamic
into this tournament suddenly Napoleon
she becomes one of the big favorites
he's got white he's got seven and a half
out of his last eight a lot of people
will be saying why not he's got you know
he's got all the momentum on his side
let's see and he's gonna
yeah he's gonna decline
Berlin go on
yeah I was gonna say it's a sigh of
relief for all of us we're not going
into that four straw variation of the
Berlin defense it's an anti-birlin as
they say not allowing the Berlin end
game with an early Queen trade this
shows a lot of ambition by napoleonishi
and he's used this opening this
variation with success already I think
in the rapid uh portion of the
tournament out there in Kazakhstan he
attacks blacks Bishop which Retreats
Hikaru Nakamura though the most
experienced player in the world on the
black side of this Pawn structure Hikaru
when he's feeling ambitious often tries
to Castle queenside and launch an attack
against the white king but meanwhile
this is still a very well known opening
Theory I'm expecting Black's Knight now
to drop back uh or for this capture to
happen we see a trade of Black's Bishop
for the White Knight I've had this
position myself I believe against vician
and a few years ago and I suffered as
black Black's Bishop looks nice and
pretty but it's not the strongest piece
uh it will later find itself caught by
some pawns potentially so a nice solid
game this one is going to be a long
maneuvering position right uh this one
is going to come down to who understands
the Strategic elements better
but this is exactly what an apology I
think
should try to aim for against Hikaru
ever so slightly better but slightly you
know strategically speaking uh
and keep the game running for as long as
possible
and try and find an opportunity if it
presents itself of course Hikaru still
big favorite to not lose
a position like this but certainly lots
of play left so I'm curious how this one
will play out
yeah and the reason that myself Lawrence
say that white is uh
strategically better at least uh
symbolically is because White's Bishop
is on the dark squares and if you look
at the Central Pawn structure Black's
Bishop potentially will got locked in
behind its own pawns on those dark
squares in terms of Pawn structure both
sides have a set of double pawns but
white has one Pawn Island all of the
white pawns protect each other whereas
Black's pawns are split into uh there's
definitely a divide in the center there
and these are very much long-term
factors which don't really play a part
in the Dynamics in the tactics of the
position which might well decide this
Blitz game which often decides Blitz
Games but uh yeah it's certainly easy
for an apology to find a plan why it's
going to put the queen on E2 what's
going to bring its Rooks to the center
and uh we will see if Nakamura can find
a productive plan of his own for black
I'm expecting him to double up Rooks on
the D file and to just sit and say okay
you can't make any more progress that
tends to be Black's most common idea in
this type of position he pushes C5
however he's pushing a pawn forward and
there we go challenging White support
edifice trying to remove his own set of
double pawns trying to trade off white
set of double Pawns interesting decision
committal long term again not
necessarily the move you want to play
but Nakamura wants the energy he wants
to pose direct questions
and on the clock that seems to be paying
off he's 30 seconds ahead as black here
Nakamura like we said yesterday Loris we
never see Nakamura behind on the clock
that's how he wins most of his Blitz
Games
yeah indeed and I think this position is
is just fine for him now uh bc5
um
the Black Knight could capture here
putting some pressure on some pawns
white opponent D3 especially tender
looking very healthy here for Nakamura
and wow Lawrence huge decision that
looks like Nakamura agreed to a draw
napoleonishi offered a draw after
capturing on C5 and wow Nakamura says
yes it just looked like he was starting
to turn things around Knight takes C5
and black would have had a very healthy
position but in the meantime we'll uh
unravel that decision later let's go to
Magnus against Rapport look at the
position here on the board looks messy
how packed is that board and we've only
seen a trade of one set of minor pieces
I believe it's just a pure mess and uh
it does look like it stemmed from a
French defense and we've joined at a
crucial moment Magnus blows open the
center by sacrificing a piece knight
takes porn he's giving up a knight on
the D5 Square he's trying to open up
those two white Bishops look at them
poised towards the black king report wow
okay he's saying okay come at me I'm a
piece up Lawrence this one could go
either way this is so much more uh kind
of topsy-turvy double-edged than the
previous game
this is really amazing I mean Magnus
going for this very speculative uh peace
sacrifice but I I don't know whether I
believe it you know Knight takes C3 now
for black uh what where where is the
compensation
if I just take this Pawn or if I bring
the queen into F5 protect a few pawns
threaten this pause
this is a this is a bluff
this is a bluff Rook B4
what am I watching
rolling the dice here Magnus Carlson
he's giving up even more material he's
landed a check but it has come at the
cost of a white Rook so he's guaranteed
to be a piece down hey he's still got
this very strong F7 Pawn Magnus Carson
uh he's now dropped his Queen back
attacking this black Bishop on the edge
of the board oh rapport's living life on
the edge with this King on A6 but if he
survives he's just a piece up Lawrence I
think you're right to be skeptical about
White's chances you're running out of
ammunition you're a whole Rook down
right now
the white Rook can't really join the
battle
class move class move they're gonna see
we're gonna see Magnus take the win
surely now
there's some a special check Queen B5
Queen D7 and queen takes
is there some Perpetual that we're
missing or what is this I'm not so sure
Black's Queen can slide into E4 give a
check grab White's rook in the corner
and you still protect along the diagonal
I think you can get away with this be
greedy Magnus is now down two Rooks for
just one bishop and he's five with pawns
desperation
is it good enough though wow A5 huge
threat of A6 black is playing without
the queen temporarily look at that white
king out in the open this is just a
crazy game black you would think must be
winning but the evaluation plus there's
no says it is a draw Magnus giving peace
odds as said there by not chicken man in
the future chat I mean it's more than
just a piece here it's two Rooks
but Magnus has a queen Magnus has a
bishop and White's King is safe from
charitable
what a concept this is
now Magnus is going to promote to a new
Queen he's going to deflect away the
black roots
giving up his valuable at some point and
he's sliding in Checkmate threatened
Lawrence like there's a rook takes F4
there's a rook takes F4 I think Magnus
this is
no no I don't think Magnus has missed
this he had to allow this now it's going
to enter
why is it Perpetual check I take I take
a bunch of Pawns I don't like Queen
is the black queen getting back in time
Checkmate is threatened Magnus has Queen
B7 on tap
can Rapport find more than a draw is
there is evaluation has reacted
is there a G5 check somewhere that's
gonna
some some sort of a check or
maybe we'll try and pull up what the
computer says because from a human point
of view it's very crazy to see
do you think
there's an age
the King has to hide like behind it no
it's over
oh my goodness
it's all over right Lawrence
look at Magnus he's taking his King off
the board it's that bad right now his
position I think you're right Rapport
has found a way the queen is going to
snake her way back using checks she's
about to give a check I think from the
H4 square is that right the queen needs
to capture on F4 The Black Queen in
order to get back surely Queen G4 just
trade the Queens
got to calculate though white has some
Pawns It's Not Over
Lawrence yeah this goodness he just
played it he's played it probably is
it's a race He's Surely ahead in the
race here though
brilliant Richard report
he's gotta promote to a new Queen both
sides will make a new Queen at the same
time but black promotes first and black
will give a bunch of checks it should be
over
Magnus makes a new queen of his own but
now some accurate checks Queen G1 slide
it across yeah
got to be winning surely now but uh
Never Say Never Lawrence Magnus still
fighting still alive
incredible game favorite game so far for
the tournament
yeah so topsy-turvy so much to unpack I
wish we could have spent hours analyzing
this game but it does look like Rapport
is going to take the win
all black needs to do is bring the queen
back he's doing that zigzag motion
getting the queen back slowly but surely
yes we'll see three he's just covering
everything beautiful stuff
by Rapport Queen F7
you've got to be careful of the mate
there's still Queen B7 check
what's King can hide from the tracks
Queen B7 is coming Rapport is he getting
nervous Magnus down to two seconds now
with his last move oh wait he's he's
blundered I know he's blundered like
this is made in your queen and now if
Queen takes GA Queen B7 it's a huge
turnaround oh my goodness me
he got nervous there he botched it and
now Magnus is the one with the extra
queen and the checkmating threats what a
game white King has lived a Charmed Life
surviving this far if it survives to the
end
wow Magnus is going to take the win
Black's Queen coming back now what a
move by Magnus Carlson a background
Checkmate giving up one of his Queens
he's won and look at magnus's face on
the camera he knows he's got away with
murder in that game Lawrence
that is one of the craziest games I've
ever seen at the world litch
Championship Magnus Carlson
dead to rights he was toast it was
forced mate for record
and Magnus comes with just an incredible
resource and Rickard missing this shot
at the end with Magnus making a new
Queen pinning the queen and therefore
forcing Rickard to accept the material
deficit I I mean that is one of the
games of the tournament surely that was
insane
I think we have to put this on the board
let's show that moment where Rapport
blundered uh allowing this really tricky
tactic from Magnus Carlson uh it was
here or it may be a couple of moves
before that he'd already let it slip but
uh let's show Queen E8 here the mistake
by Rapport yeah Rapport had safer ways
to win the game of course he was still
winning this for example here the move
Rook C6 check was a fairly simple win
because after King F5 Queen F2 and you
just collect the queen
fairly simple stuff
Rapport went with the checks which is
the natural human thing to do but
already around here things are tricky
again while threatening the mates and
threatening to make a queen and it was
here where Rapport played this horrific
move Queen E8 looks like it wins because
feels like you forced a trade of Queens
but now after G8 Queen all of a sudden
you protect the queen
so if Queen's X queen queen takes Queen
is just an easy win
and if you take the Queen off here you
deflect away from the pin which raffle
was relying on
all of a sudden it's mate What A Swindle
and what a
change in momentum I mean that is that
that has just got such tremendous
implications
for the tournament
instead of Hikaru being out in front
alone
and Magnus being what would it be a
point and a half no he would be uh
a point behind
now Magnus has clawed his way back in
Hikaru will be fuming
watching that result
unbelievable stuff
I've got to say Lawrence as well we
mentioned it beforehand when Rapport
took a quick draw with white against
Nakamura we talked about the chess Gods
how the chess guards tend to punish you
if you take negative decisions with
white and the next game he gets black
against Magnus completely winning
and it Slips Away uh we could blame bad
luck but is it karma uh reports yeah so
close one move away but not finishing
off and Magnus taking his chances uh
when they came uh I mean we had to focus
on that game it was too dramatic maybe
we can uh just mention some of the other
results that did come in uh
some massive results uh altimia Beats
duboff
to launch him within Striking Distance
on set and a half giri also with a
massive result speaking beating and
draking with white that means that
Carlson and Nakamura on 11 points Gary
artimiev are on Ten and a half and some
uh some names that perhaps uh we're not
so familiar with remember that kid that
beats manager of well he's now beaten
feather save
to boot
so we've got mad damn enough who's just
beaten bluebound managera from
Philadelphia in a row he's suddenly on
10 points and apomnushy is on 10 points
Kmart 10 points and jul Musa also on
some points just to point back so
they are still within it and I should
say if we look at the women's section we
didn't have a chance because that game
was just so crazy azerbai Eva has done
it she has ended the streak of Valentina
gunina the reigning women's Blitz World
Champion has beaten Valentina yeah
also held shuvalova
meaning suddenly that tournament is also
wide open shovel over on nine gunina on
eight and a half and then a pack of
players on eight should be pointed out
that tanjong ji has lost a game for the
first time in what seems like a long
time to harika so that means that harika
allows the rest of the fields of Peg
back there absolutely unbelievable stuff
and uh
that tournament wide open
yeah I think we need to catch our breath
after all of that Lawrence there's still
seven rounds left of the open uh
blitzwar championship and six rounds
left in the women's so we'll see more
twists and turns ahead that is
guaranteed but Carlson has caught up
with Nakamura and uh we will be back in
a few minutes to uh yeah unpack all the
drama all the action
life is full of exciting events but it
is our first impressions that we
remember best your first diploma
[Applause]
your first job in a big company
Unforgettable emotions from the first
date the first expensive things you
bought when you got your first paycheck
and your first Investments with freedom
broker Freedom broker look at your
favorite brands from A New Perspective
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome back to the
final day of this year's World Blitz
chess championships from Kazakhstan uh
we've just seen an unbelievable round of
chess the game between the Anna
publishini garudakamura ended very
peacefully very quickly Jana publisher
deciding not to go for it
it was all eyes on Magnus Carlson
against record Rapport and my goodness
what a game looked as though Rapport was
just completely winning
and Magnus well anishkiri has been
quoted as calling Magnuson magician and
with reason
if we look at the following position on
the board David if we look here we can
see
black has got two Rooks and a queen
versus queen and Bishop but the black
king in some kind of trouble some kind
of mating net the queen never gets here
uh black is going to be toast now the
move that mag has actually chose in the
game was a losing one but perhaps we can
show our viewers
uh an incredible moment here where
Magnus actually could have uh won the
game
yeah and for those who were watching
this game live with us you could sense
the adrenaline for the two players you
could sense uh just how quickly they
were trying to calculate how
energetically they were both playing but
the winning move here Lawrence was just
to take a time out to take a breather
and it's so counter-intuitive F3
blocking the black Queen's diagonal
blocking its contact with the D5 square
and miraculously the white king is safe
there's no way to break through to that
white king just to show A variation uh
if black plays G6 for example setting up
a Checkmate threat of Queen takes H5 and
white just captures on G6
um and after H5 the king sits happily
nice and pretty on G5 uh maybe F5 but
maybe G5 is a safer square and either
way there is a threat no matter what
black does of playing the move Magnus
actually chosen the game uh f8 Queen uh
let's say black pushes a pawn uh H4 uh
then white makes a new Queen with f8
deflecting away this Rook on d8 and uh
that checkmating pattern does arise on
the board checkmating along the
diagonals and Magnus missed this uh
which is fully understandable we can't
blame him F3 is such a difficult move
but he promoted first the wrong order
because as we saw in the game Lawrence
suddenly Rook takes F4 was allowed and
this series of checks should have been
winning for black we were all I mean we
were both calling that report was on the
brink of Victory because one or two
moves away yeah there was another turn
around Lawrence yeah he found this great
move G5 which is necessary this is all
correct this is correct King F3 this is
correct this is correct and then he
traded Queens which is also correct it's
not the end of the game though because
here it looks as though wow Black's got
an extra Rook but these two pawns are
very fast B5 was correct by Rapport and
he understood he has to create his own
Queen quickly before these two pawns
March down now it's a race who creates
the queen first this is what we got and
wrap up with the extra Rook before white
can Queen his own Pawn should be winning
C3 was fine this is all still fine and
this is the moment here where Rapport
starts to go wrong because it's in this
position believe it or not this position
here you can see by the bar is actually
a draw there's now no decent way to
prevent mate and the promotion of this
Pawn instead all Rapport had to do was
play them with Rook C6 check forcing
King F5 only move and then Queen F2
check scoring the king and queen and the
King moves out where you win the queen
and Magnus would have resigned
missed missed opportunity there by
Rapport but it's not only just that he
ended up losing this game it's the fact
that Magnus won it
you know from being dead lost to winning
that is a two-point full swing
um and of course with that win it means
he ties things up with Hikaru Nakamura
at the top
and suddenly we have a really tense
event
yeah what a game Lawrence I think maybe
the most dramatic game I've seen
throughout the history of the world
Blitz Championship five different Queens
appeared on the board uh during that
game and uh on that note we do see the
standings and it is really getting tight
now and Magnus Carlsen has indeed caught
up with Hikaru Nakamura they sit nice
and pretty out there on the lead on 11
points after 14 games Anish giri and
Daniel dubov only half a point behind
within Striking Distance I think I think
we'll see more big pairings there uh
yankov
winning after his uh setback against
Magnus at the beginning of the day and
janaponishi they are all chasing as well
um yeah Anything could happen at this
point I think our prediction game we
could just throw it out the window
because we'll see uh so many more uh
twists and turns I think we'll see
players take even more risks as both
Carlson and Rapport did in that game
because these are the crunch rounds
these are the money runs and
no matchups yet let's check out the
standings in the women's section
Lawrence
absolutely
yeah oh okay well
uh in the in the uh in the women's
section we don't yet have a
uh a pure update
uh but we will uh I will just mention
that there is a clear leader uh in the
form of Paulina shuvolova who are is
half a point clear of gunina after
gunina's loss against azerbayeva the
reigning women's Blitz World Champion
and then there's a bunch of players on 8
out of 11. so it's shuval over on nine
gunina eight and a half and then harika
tanjong ji
koyageva and Sarah kadam also starting
to sneak into the mix with eight out of
11.
great great uh tournament there as well
we're going to be covering both you can
see the playing ball they're old and
young alike
uh enjoying the atmosphere enjoying the
spectacle
and what a spectacle it is great
tournament
uh
just a fantastic uh you know camaraderie
amongst the players as well you'd love
to see
that uh there is that social side you
get to catch up with people you get to
enjoy being in the presence of greatness
some of the best players in the world
in Kazakhstan a lot of local fans as
well watching the action
one of local players
if we think about what just happened in
the women's section for example
Kazakhstan still has a shot at having
another world champion this year
um
should be pointed out that I I cannot
see for the life of me
uh where
uh
uh uh janzai Abdul Malik she's had I've
had to scroll right the way down she's
had a catastrophic
Blitz event she's on 50 percent
which is absolutely no good for her
so all the popes lying with
the current Wildlife Champion bibisara
asubai Eva
she still has a chance
you know you're right Lawrence
Kazakhstan do have a silver medal from
the world rapid Championship the Women's
World rapid Championship but they will
be looking to go one better in the Blitz
and meanwhile we do have the match-ups
they've just come through and
we've seen nothing yet because no
problem actually against Carson yet
another game that promises uh drama that
promises a potential upset it's not
going to be easy that for Carlson
Nakamura faces artemiev one of the best
players in the world rapid tournament
I'll tell me if he's got to play the
spoiler role now can he take down
Nakamura who hasn't won today yet he's
on a roll of two drawers so far and uh
of that kind of uh top Bunch there dubov
faces Mata rosian Harry Krishna faces
giri interesting Clash there between two
very good friends
against Duda predictions Lawrence
especially Napoleon against Carlson a
rematch of the 2021 World Championship
tough one tough one to say in a
publishing with white uh looks as though
the chest gods are smiling upon Magnus
Carlsen though and when they start to
smile upon Him normally they don't turn
that smile upside down
uh I'm gonna go with a Carlson non-loss
so I'm going with a draw or win for
Magnus
too much is going his way quick draws in
nakamura's game the fact that he wanna
really boring playing position against
Marta rosian the fact that he turned
that losing position around all the
chips are falling uh for Magnus Carlson
uh
just can't bet against him Nakamura
against altimia think this is a bad
pairing for our teamiev in general I
think nakamura's got quite a decent
score against him I think it's a good
pairing for dubov as well just to stay
relevant as is for Geary I think Gary
will be happy to be black against Harry
who is somebody we've not really
featured at all
um and then we'll see the rest of the
games
we also have the standings for the
women's tournament uh Paulina shuvalova
thanks to her draw in the last round has
established a sole lead after Valentina
gunina dropped points and gunina still
outright second but there's a closing in
we see harika tanzong Yi uh goliachkin
the current Blitz World Champion
and as you mentioned a bit earlier
Lawrence Sarah cardem Sarah Sharia and
uh there's been a lot of talk about her
recently she's just moved to Spain I'm
hearing I read yesterday and um yeah we
won't get into any politics here but she
has been making statements uh throughout
the tournament and she's a very popular
player very strong player she's had an
up and down rapid tournament but now in
the blitz she is on a streak she's been
winning a bunch of games and don't write
her off anyone here in the top 10 still
capable of taking the title still a long
way to go with six rounds left
and we do see the pairings as you
mentioned earlier shrivel over against
assuable
big game Lawrence massive game massive
massive game uh absolutely necessary for
us very ever not to lose I think if
Asbury ever loses this one
um shivanova is just suddenly huge
favorite to take down the tournament
because a fear for gunina Sara Academy
is a really really decent player with
the white pieces and uh I think uh she's
actually you know in a in a bit of a
stride at the moment Sarah got him so I
think a lot of players are banking on
bibisara not to lose to make sure the
tournament remains competitive
on the screen though we see this already
very familiar match up neponishi White
against Magnus Carlsen
is napomnushi going to upset the balance
it's been all Magnus Carlson so far
he's had luck he's had the Run of uh the
draw he's he he's just had everything
going his way at the start today let's
watch and find out yeah here we go
Lawrence will napomnishi repeat the
opening that we saw him choose against
Hikaru Nakamura it's another Berlin Wall
a Berlin defense uh Napoli she says no
it's another anti-burling and still this
is completely identical to that earlier
game Agnes was he watching does he know
how Nakamura diffused White's opening
Choice here in that game Nakamura
retreated the bishop back to B6 here
Magnus chooses a different move if
you're back to D6 also a theoretical uh
idea still very well known stuff but it
has caused the publishi to pause for the
first time in the game I'm expecting him
to Castle there we go and which way will
Magnus Carlson Castle I think that will
show a lot about his intentions if
Magnus moves his Q in right now and
tries to Castle on the queen side then
we will see blood we will see Magnus go
all out it's very risky however to put
your King on the opposite flank to your
opponent if we see magnets just take
your time out and Castle kingside mirror
his opponent then we'll see a slower
Karma type of position so key moment in
terms of the type of position we'll
we'll see but Magnus is costing him a
lot of time he needs to make that
stylistic decision and he needs to make
it quickly upon your sheet are you
disappointed that he offered a draw to
Nakamura in the previous round it felt
like that was his shot he's getting
another chance now Lawrence
well uh I maybe there wasn't that much
in the positions it's not the worst
drawer offer I've ever seen I think what
Rapport did against that Marine round
one is just unforgivable in a blitz
tournament in a in a classical
tournament Shore if it's a position
where Rapport is locking up a price
short with nine rounds to go how can you
how can you force a draw like this uh
with the white pieces you've got to be
optimistic
um so uh we'll see whether that early
draw by nepo backfires but I like his
position Knight A5 I mean queen C8 and
now you play B3 you put the bishop on B2
isn't this what uh what you desire in
these sorts of positions
yeah it's exactly what the doctor
ordered if you want a flexible position
and some winning chances as white Magnus
castles Magnus needs to unravel his
pieces untangle very quickly uh there
will be pressure as you mentioned there
Lawrence on Black's E5 Pawn White's
Knight jumps back now towards the center
and Magnus Retreats the one positive
behind Black's position is the bishop
pair but Napoleon she says nope you're
not having that any longer I'm going to
trade off pieces I'm going to get rid of
your light Squad bishop and Magnus is
forced to part with it and we will see
now whether Black start Square Bishop
becomes an issue black star Square
Bishop looks like a big Pawn right now
you've got to say stuck behind its own
Pawn chain and it's all about the
knights can they maneuver to better
squares it's very very blocked but that
should only favor white with the
superior minor pieces right now I'm just
looking at one bad piece here for black
Lawrence and I think that that might
well be a long-term deciding factor
yes but on the other hand what is white
supposed to do here uh it's not totally
clear to me where his levers are I think
Magnus he decides to go F5 which I'm
really surprised about actually
this is a pretty impulsive decision by
the way Magnus a full minute behind on
the clock as well which is relevant
because napometry is a very fast player
I hate F5 as a move
um just don't understand why for example
in this position after Knight F3 uh why
he didn't play what I think he was going
to play Knight B8 rerouting into C6 and
staying solid now he has this uh awful E
Pawn I don't actually get the move at
all I think this is a really really poor
practical decision by Magnus and I'm now
something very very excited about Yan's
chances is a minute and a half up on the
clock better position
this is a dream situation
yeah I think that's an understatement
Lawrence this is more than a dream for
white right now uh like you said the
clock could be a huge factor it's going
to play a role in the next phase of the
game Magnus down to around 30 seconds
he's again giving his opponent Thai mods
and there are already threats on the
board against Black's isolated E Pawn if
white ever lands with a knight in front
of it on the E4 Square as well then uh
things will look very bad for black I
think a moment ago over nepo's shoulder
we saw that Hare Krishna and giri have
finished maybe we can find a result
there but meanwhile we see a bit of
maneuvering from both sides
magnificently stabilized blacks Queen
and Rook on the f-file make a nice
impression but napoleonishi is going
around now with that white knight to its
dream outpost on e4 and still an uphill
struggle black yeah he just has one bad
piece that dark Square bishop and
napoleonishi will play against it long
term
maybe Magnus has avoided the worst he's
uh avoided any immediate Knockouts
immediate blows but still long-term
suffering here on the board and the
clock can nepo capitalize
what's he doing here he's retreating all
of his pieces to the background he's not
setting up for the next game he's just
trying to get his Queen out the way
maybe he'll try and stack up his Rooks
but Magnus is the king of maneuvering
and Black's night now shooting to f8
which I don't hate the Knight is coming
around to E6 and from there maybe
fresher pastures
but napoleonishi this is what happens
when you have a better Pawn structure
your pieces automatically find nice
outposts and retreating the Knight
hitting Black's Rook I love what
Napoleon 10 seconds not only for Magnus
Carlson he has to play almost
instantaneously
you have to pre-move pretty much here
and uh where's the black queen gonna
hide I think nepo has the chance to
force a draw if he wants to repeat moves
but he should definitely steer clear of
that option uh he can keep harassing the
black queen with his Knight and nowhere
to run look at this from nepo though he
brings this bishop out saying yes you
can trade off this bishop for your
knight but then we'll see a good night
against Bad Bishop scenario why it's not
only four will dominate uh so Magnus
avoids any exchanges six seconds
Lawrence
surely surely that's going to decide
this game how can Magnus avoid any
blunders with only six seconds
I mean I would be shocked if nepo
doesn't press here he doesn't have to do
anything too crazy he can play a bit
calm don't blunder anything that's the
key maybe play Move Like H4 just support
some of your pieces
um
yeah I think H4 is streaming to be
screaming out to be played
H4 contains a hidden threat as well
Lawrence to trap The Black Queen I love
it uh H4 maybe we can just show that
with some arrows uh okay he doesn't play
that immediately he hits that black
queen which has only one safe square
there's a potential discovered attack
against her right now look at the G file
as well
all squares on the G file are occupied
by pawns or pieces a very rare formation
but nepo repeating the position Magnus
you got to move four seconds no no hey
second time I've seen this position now
surely nepo won't repeat yet again you
can't you can't repeat here
you cannot if you want to be world
champion these are the spots you've got
to take you cannot be tame here no don't
do it
okay
good and okay he's forced a favorable
exchange we do see that good night
against Bad Bishop scenario now White's
night can never ever be removed from the
E4 square and Black's Bishop
just a problem piece a terrible piece
but Magnus has activated slightly he's
forced a set of Rooks off the board
improving his own Pawn structure
Lawrence lacks e-pawn the previous
isolated eporn no longer uh it's turned
into a slightly healthier F Pawn now but
still the problem of the bishop against
the knight in Practical terms still
you've got a favor white right this is a
dream for why rookie one king F1 will be
played
uh protecting The Rook allowing
discoveries yes this is the correct the
correct way one second he's going to
lose on time
Magnus Carson wow flagged we said that
that might decide the game and it
literally did the clock uh tough
position you've got to say for Magnus
Carlson nepo was the favorite on the
board but huge result for the standings
let's go to Hikaru Nakamura who's still
in play 12 seconds against five
he's also in trouble Hikaru Nakamura
he's much worse against artemia with the
black pieces
this is an incredible
he's two pulls down he's dead lost
objectively
and he's getting mated
no he's not he's surviving
Checkmate that white king surely won't
survive
and it's running white King has run away
running for the Hills
blocks but another Pawn is falling with
a check you can trade off the Queens why
didn't he swap the Queens off there it's
all right he can do here
yeah it's all over tell me if it's going
to take the win
wow
what a round on the top two boards there
just to keep everybody uh up to date in
the whims section we didn't have a
chance but I said way over unable to
stop the train that is Paulina shovel
over and Sarah Academy I said it was a
bad bad game potentially for Valentina
saric Adam beats Valentina goodina so
shovel over a full point clear now is
Sarah Adam gonna come from behind and do
the unexpected let's see if there are
any more games for us to check out in
the open section it looks as though all
the top boards
have actually finished I'm just wow I
mean talk about turning this tournament
upside down Nakamura ankles and both
losing
in the same round and suddenly we have a
new leader David Howe vladison Timmy
have
yeah we'll talk about the standings in a
moment we just see a game there with
goyachukina and a handshake it looks
like back has one in that game tanzong
taking down go yakina who loses on the
board and the clock another huge game
for the standings in the women's section
I mean at this point we barely know
who's in the lead or we know that
shrivolova is doing well in the women's
section but in the open it's wide open
yet again and I mean I mean at this
point it's it's a coin flip it's a
toss-up
I mean this is just brilliant for us
because now
it's anybody's tournament we've got
vladislava Timmy a clear leader beating
Hikaru Nakamura
he's got a half Point advantage over
Nakamura Carlson Geary napomnushy
Vincent Kamar Jewel Musa is suddenly a
half a point behind it is quite
astonishing
lots of players catching up now there we
saw Eric icy beating Young volodar
mertzin
I mean so many decisive games barely a
draw in sight in this last round
bloodthirsty round and yeah as you
mentioned Lawrence it's just it's just
chaos in that playing Hall in that
Auditorium out there in Kazakhstan I
don't know what's in the air but I'm
loving it I've got to say uh the players
are going all out now we see a clash
between Vladimir ivich and Johann
Sebastian Christensen Grandmaster from
Norway uh can't see the board that well
but it looks like a queen against two
Bishops could this be a fortress for
white Lawrence what a crazy game this is
maybe not as important for the standings
as some of the others but just as wild
just as crazy uh White Bishop's doing a
good job of holding their own against
the queen
yes but I doubt this is ever a fortress
because you can go King E6 yeah and if
H7 Queen C2 check wins the porn
uh uh you can go King D6 well
however Sebastian's gonna win this
however hold on a second
however
yeah they do a good job of helping the
White H Pawn forward if given the time
if given the opportunity right now the
black queen guards the white dark Square
Bishop so there's no chance of pushing
the H Pawn but yeah somehow Black's
Queen is fighting a lone fight she
doesn't have any support here but nice
move there by black Johann Sebastian a
classy Blitz and bullet player dropping
the black queen back he's got a run with
the king the queen needs some support
but now can black breakthrough who
living life on the edge here Max King is
coming you're right Lawrence this might
be the killer idea uh this
King now surely is going to help the
Queen deliver Checkmate some mating
patterns already in the air and white
pawns are dropping
this should spell the end why H6 Pawn
can be captured as well
once that goes it's all over because you
can just run the other Pawn
and no chance here for ivich to save
unless
yeah and we see a handshake black takes
the win and Johann Sebastian Christensen
the Norwegian making up for Norway's
disappointment of Magnus Carlson losing
in that last round
yeah absolutely
brilliant stuff what around you couldn't
have really written it better the
publishing beating Carlson
with the white pieces Hikaru Nakamura
losing with the white pieces to artemiev
and then a bunch of players able to
catch them up we're going to go and
catch our breath we'll be back
for the next round and with the pairings
for the next round very very soon all of
a sudden
there are literally eight players who
can now win this thing it's gonna be
really really fascinating to see who
holds their nerve in the following
rounds don't go anywhere continued
coverage of the wildlife Championship
here on chess.com in just a few seconds
life is full of exciting events but it
is our first impressions that we
remember best your first diploma
your first job in a big company
edible emotions from the first date the
first expensive things you bought when
you got your first paycheck and your
first Investments with freedom broker
Freedom broker look at your favorite
brands from A New Perspective
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
everybody and welcome back to coverage
of the final day of the world Blitz
chess championships
it has just been well we're still
catching our breath from the fire from
the last round what an incredible set of
events
uh the tournament in the open section
has just been blown wide open
Magnus Carlsen losing against the
underpometer she and Hikaru Nakamura who
has had a rotten start to the day two
draws and a loss losing against
vladislavartime with white pieces
has meant that suddenly
it's anybody's tournament
it is in fact vladislava artimiev
leading the tournament with a whole
bunch of players just a half Point
behind him David I'm still kind of
trying to get to grips with what just
happened I'm still in a bit of shock
um Lawrence if we check out the
standings I think there's still five
leaders uh I think our teammate is still
half a point back he had a big upload in
the last game so all right Carlson
yeah Nakamura and Carlson despite both
losing in the same round I would have
bet my house that that would never
happen but uh despite Nakamura and
Carson losing in the same round they
still share the lead and they have been
joined by Anish giri hike Marty rosian
bit of a surprise there and of course
Jana publisher who has scored nine
points out of his last 10 games so he's
the man on form right now he's the man
who just took down Magnus Carlson and
look at how many players are chasing
them Duda or tamev and dubov all just
half a point up uh off lead and another
big group on 10 points too and on that
note we can check out the matchups we
see Carlson against Vincent kaimer the
silver medalist uh from the world rapid
Championship up against the gold
medalist from the world rapid uh that's
gonna be huge Carlson did beat Vincent
uh just a couple of days ago in that
tournament Gary against neponishi
anyone's game there Mata rosian against
feder save and Nakamura dropping down to
board four he started the day one point
clear he's now sharing the lead but he
plays three-time Blitz World Champion
Alexander grishek uh from there still
some very juicy pairings
and plenty more but yeah it's going to
be hard to choose where to focus our
attentions on because yet again Lawrence
the stakes are higher than ever and uh
here we see giri and napomnia she's
sharing a laugh
yeah I think this is a great bounce back
spot though for Magnus Carlson I think
you'll be very happy with this
particular pairing Vincent is of course
a great player but his record against
Magnus is particularly poor
and Gary if he wants can be Uber solid
and uh
you know uh Alexander grishek can can
also cause an upset former blitzworld
champion
so again despite what happened in the
last round I think that this is a
magnificent opportunity for Magnus to
reinstate his uh his leadership on this
tournament should also be pointed out
that in the women's section
uh shuvalova a full point clear playing
Black against Sarah Academy massive
massive game I do like Sarah Academy
though with the white pieces in that
game she's won four in a row she's
beaten casteno she's beaten goonie now
she's beaten but delka
um she's clearly
in really good form and sure but of
course shivanova as you can see on the
screen there rocking the pink hair
uh in fantastic shape but Star Academy I
told you sorry especially with the white
pieces I find that to be a very very
serious opponent and this could rip that
one open wide open as well if Sarah Adam
manages to win with the white pieces all
of a sudden you could get a pile up at
the top in the women's section so things
totally unclear as we reach really the
uh uh sort of halfway stage of today's
action
yeah and here we go we are off uh the
games have started remember it's not
about how you start the tournament it's
about how you finish as you say Lawrence
there it's the second half now entering
the second half soon of the final day uh
it's the money rounds and we are
focusing on the game between Anish giri
and janapomnishi the man in form winning
so many games over the last few rounds
and it's a very dry variation of the
Queen's gamma decline this is something
we saw yesterday when Hikaru Nakamura
took on Magnus Carlson it's what we call
the Berlin of 1d4 lots of exchanges
Queens are off the board we'll most
likely see a night for Bishop exchange
black is temporarily one Pawn up but
White's Bishop pair more than
compensates and white has various ways
to at least equalize this of course uh
Gary brings his Bishop out mirroring
what Nakamura tried against Magnus
yesterday and they're I think magnus's
antidote as black let's just pick up a
pawn and uh challenge that Bishop but
okay first we see Black's night develop
white is is going to
hey bring the light Square Bishop out
I'm loving the activity of White's
pieces but still of course a very well
known position Black's King often now
mobilizes and starts leading from the
front starts defending some pawns there
we go still Mainline Theory and I think
it is time for upon Yoshi to start
challenging white pieces we see a Night
Exchange
Gary obtaining the bishoper long-term
Advantage risk-free position Lawrence
surely this suits Gary's Style
well yes it does uh to a certain extent
but as we saw in the uh Hikaru Nakamura
Magnus Carlson game is really not much
here for white this is a slightly better
version than what uh Hikari got against
Magnus I feel but at the same time I'm
not hugely concerned for Jan napomnushy
as things stand
uh I agree Lauren so with that in mind
let's check out a very dramatic game
let's go over to Magnus Carlson against
absolutely Vincent climber there's
fireworks on the board potentially in
this one it's still early days of course
but Magnus is declaring his intentions
he's pushed his G Pawn forward look at
how Magnus hasn't castled either he's
trying to hunt down Black's light
squared bishop and Vincent Connor very
calmly just offering a trade of pieces
here trying to get the dark Square
Bishops off the board Magnus slightly
ahead on the clock remember mag just
lost on time in the last game that
happens once in a blue moon normally
he's got great control over the clock
but uh this time he won't want a
repetition of that incident okay he does
trade off a set of pieces after kicking
Black's Bishop back from E5 and I think
Magnus is going to stay flexible I don't
think he really wants to Castle uh with
his King yet he wants to keep Vincent
guessing maybe a move such as E3 put the
White Queen on E2 there we go E3 played
and which side is the white king going
we'll again be able to tell a lot from
magnus's next few moves Vincent
meanwhile playing very quickly very
confidently he loves this Pawn structure
Vincent with uh pawns on e65 rock solid
uh foundations for black Magnus
committal pushing for G5 last night yeah
either has to retreat to a bad square or
sit on the edge of the board where it
might no uh might never join the action
again Knight takes five Lawrence
doesn't look like a very good piece
there for Vincent you've got to say and
uh Magnus yeah
I'm not entirely sure because it's a
it's a strange one the Knight actually
does a great job of uh protecting the G7
Pawn you can now bring a rooked C8
employ some pressure that feels like
there's some Queen side pressure to be
had here
um not entirely sure that this is so
great for Magnus actually Rook C8 played
and you can see Magnus now paused I
think he's starting to realize that
actually he's got a few issues here on
the queen side
um there's some Queen A5 checks that are
coming
uh Queen B6 moves and he decides the
castle along wow
committal decision he's basically
pinning a flag to his King and saying
come at me this is a target for you but
I guess his ideas to attack on the
opposite flank later I must admit
earlier Lawrence visually I find it
difficult to see if the black the Black
Knight on H5 does defend G7 uh uh just
uh very kind of strange type of setup
there Vincent meanwhile threatens
Checkmate in one Queen takes C2 monster
threat Magnus defends with his Rook
yeah suddenly Vincent if you can get
some energy bringing his Knight in he's
trying to get to E4 Magnus has some big
questions to answer retreating every
turn now Magnus Knight E1
threat was nice a lot of white light
Square Bishop now guards E4
great move 91 I think actually a
difficult move to play but a great one
that also sets up some Bishop F3 Bishop
takes H5 ideas
uh because of the threats along the long
diagonal so this is a this is a very
uh kind of standard threat I think this
was actually an absolutely critical move
for Magnus to find and he did it quickly
he's up on the clock I think the
momentum is back in magnus's favor
probably still good for black
but how is the question Rick fd8
okay Rook 58 and King B1 B1 Yep this
side shuffle anytime you cast a queen
side you should always try and Shuffle
towards the corner
um it's basically mirroring King side
castling on the other flank your king is
always much safer when it's not being
stared down by an opponent's Queen and
Rook so I'm loving that last move by
Magnus also throwing the ball back into
the opponent's Court saying okay I'm not
sure what my plan is I'm not sure what
yours is either and look at this
Vincent's spent a lot of time there but
he's throwing everything at Magnus now
the kitchen sink has been thrown in he's
pushing Black's Central Pawns
I've not seen the idea immediately I
think he's just trying to open things up
open up those lines for the black Rooks
he is banking on the fact that Black's
pieces are more ready and more
coordinated than whites you've got to
look at the White Knight now and that
white rook in the corner on H1
struggling really to get in the game
there and Magnus says okay I'm not going
to take that black pawn I'm not going to
gamble with things opening up
plays Knight F3 and Vincent D3
wow setting up some tricks against the
white king potentially if this Pawn is
captured twice
E4 look at the mess we've suddenly got
91 but is is black overextending here
could be five
yeah it's like Magnus is cutting up into
a ball here just all out defense backs
to the wall but instant like you said
overextended potentially and what has
happened here
wow my queen the White Queen on G4
controls C8 Vincent wow just an
oversight there hallucinating big win
for Magnus Carlson actually from a
difficult position let's see Lawrence if
there are other games going on the top
few boards uh is Nakamura still going
isn't a promise he's still going against
Gary
let's find out we do see Nakamura is
playing we see Magnus as well
spectating you're biting luckily not
standing in front of the camera thank
you Magnus but uh it's looking very
balanced in this one you've got to say
who do you favor here Lawrence
probably ever so slightly favored white
I feel like the knight in general is a
more tricky piece to play against
um
but it's very very marginal and
objectively probably things are level
but well the big time Advantage Sasha
has to play a move oh he plays it with
me that was a second
yeah but has that blundered upon oh Rook
takes E6 was interesting there but okay
Rook F3 and bang Hikaru plays a winning
tactic Rook takes F7 there would be a
night Fork on E6 next move and trick off
as his hand resigns Nakamura taking an
important win those two favorites
causing that Nakamura now the chips are
down they will start to up their game
great uh finish spectacular finish to
that one
for sure losing his chances to uh mount
a comeback and uh what else is still
going on here it looks like Duda is
playing dubov in an important Clash for
the top of the table and uh what is
happening on the board
oh this doesn't look like them on the
camera no we're looking at their
position on
this is this is much of Russian against
feather save let's check in with that
game but black is a rook down white has
an extra Rook simply unless I'm counting
wrong Lawrence black has two pawns but
that's not sufficient compensation
in the lead he's about to continue that
hot streak and join Carson and Nakamura
on uh what is it 12 points wow Mata
rosian he might have suffered a defeat
against Magnus at the start of the day
but bouncing back in impressive Style
he's guaranteed yeah
well not guaranteed but certainly you
would you would expect that he would win
trading a pair of Rooks as often the way
to do it
but
you can win this Pawn as well yeah this
is this is pretty hopeless uh now for
blackish with the pawns gone
two Rooks are better than one
that's what they say they are
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah we'll see a check from black
don't take the rookie stalemate but you
just Retreat and black is doomed
Checkmate incoming and we see this clock
stopped at the same resigns
what a win by the young Armenian
great win by matarosa
in the women's checks section should be
pointed out shuvalova has extended her
lead well rather she wins a critical
game against Sarah cardum and tanjanji
beats Katrina Loughner with the white
pieces that means tanjong ji just a
point behind shival over and they have
already played oh Lawrence we're just
watching the game between gunina and
hampi canero and gunina flagged in what
looked like a rawish position or the
nerves are getting to everyone now
losing on time she's had a tough few
rounds uh over the last few hours oh
yeah the streak she was leading the
remember at the start of the day joint
with shrivel over but humpy taking a win
and gaining some ground still quite far
two points behind shrivel over but
important for the standings over that I
mean while we see the auditorium players
starting to leave now starting to go out
take a break and uh we will be back but
there are still some games going here we
see Dura Bailey who is durability up
against here I'm not not too familiar
with the player with the black pieces
and this is
let me look
either way you're Rob Bailey a very
important game maybe someone can check
this
white is doing pretty well on the board
it looks like with a clock playing a big
factor will this end in a draw level
material Queen and Knight against Queen
and Bishop which are the superior Duo
board 48 here and this is durability
against tin
from Singapore from the country of my
mother's birth actually and uh
doing very well at the Olympiad earlier
this year four seconds for black but can
he stem the tide can he find a reply oh
one second he made that with oh it's
Queen is coming
now the white king very well placed but
some checks from behind for the black
queen potentially he should hold the
draw but durability is going all in
trying everything possible
no more checks though uh unless
the white king can't hide Lawrence the
white king isn't come up going on a
journey going on an adventure
and oh that's the very nervous move king
h8 that's not a good Square for the king
checks continue but whites oh he knocked
over a piece there
losing the summer time for his opponent
on the move and White's King has come
the whole way around
it's hard to call but I'm gonna say this
is going to be a white win look at that
King look how Brave he's been with that
piece that's uh three result game oh two
seconds for the for white there
handy assistant now consolidate
it feels like it's still very holdable
exactly six
maybe white needs to support the reverse
breaks here uh yeah suddenly all the way
back
run away
and uh you have the King on G4 should be
very safe I think we'll we'll see this
game uh just settle down a bit now feels
like black is better be careful there's
some Queen G2
Queen G2 chicks exist Queen F3 is mate
uh King H7 he's gonna self-mate himself
and he decides to protect against Queen
F3 mate now Queen G2 is coming in though
G6 is going to be more Knight f8 black
is winning or he loses on time as he
makes the move to Rabbi Lee he Flags so
many players losing on time now as the
tiredness kicks in what a win turning it
around
and beside himself
frustratingly smashing the table we've
all been there when you're pressing and
pressing and pressing you lose on time
and in a fit of rage smashes the table
remember so many prizes up for grabs so
much money on the line even uh a game
like this can be the difference between
thousands of dollars
durability sick at losing that game on
time but that is
how it goes brutal brutal stuff what
around
yeah what around this has been as you
mentioned Lawrence there's 35 prizes in
the open section uh here we see there's
more games going
um this is a Tusa from Iran with the
white pieces and uh it does look like a
dead drawn End Game Night important
against bishop and pawn this one should
fizzle out to a draw soon and uh atuza
kukashian I believe against Lara Schultz
from Germany and there we go a draw is
the result remember lots of prices as
well available in the women's section so
every point every half Point matters
it's never too late to go on a search
and claim some of those big money prizes
like you said every price is Thousands
pretty much so everyone has something to
play for
still plenty of time left
plenty of action to be had and uh
Lawrence I don't know if there are any
games still ongoing we see the
tournament Hall here we often look out
for the crowds the crowds of Spectators
gathering around a single board but no
it looks like
around 16 is over for the open section
absolutely is we're going to take a
short break as per usual but we'll be
back with the next round all of a sudden
Magnus Hikaru starting to
re-impose himself but is the young gonna
hike Marta rosian who's sticking around
with the leaders going to cause more of
an upset don't forget and don't sleep on
Geary dubov are timmyev and napoleonishi
just half Point behind
it's anybody's uh tournament still
plenty of Chess left to play we'll be
right back with continued coverage this
year's free day Wildlife championships
don't go anywhere
your subscription makes shows like this
possible which is why our twitch
subscribers will never see ads on
chess.com
connectyourchess.com account and Twitch
account at go.chess.com connect accounts
and bang boom voila you're done 100 AD
free Bliss forevermore whether you're
following our events on site or on
stream type the command connect in the
chat and thank you for helping bring
these shows to life
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and everybody and welcome back to
chest.com's coverage of the final day of
the feed a Blitz World Championships but
the open and the women's sections and
things are getting more unpredictable by
the minutes before we review what
happened uh in the previous round do uh
remember that the wait for the new era
the new season of the protest league is
over after a two-year Hiatus the protest
league is finally back the 2023 season
begins with a qualifier week starting
February the 1st 16 teams Advance into
the main season and if you do want to
play in the uh in the protest League you
will have a chance playing against some
of the biggest names in the game past
participants have included Magnus
Carlson himself Dean liren Anish
and so on and obviously everybody at
jets.com is extremely excited for the
League's return there'll be over 100k in
prizes on the line as well so it's gonna
be one for these three books make sure
to check out uh the protest League use
exclamation mark PCL in the chat to
learn more
okay back to the world Blitz
championships and David we have been
treated to the kind of drama that every
chess fan loves to see
but still despite everything it is
Hikaru and Magnus out in front
that's right and I hope all the viewers
have their popcorn Hikaru Nakamura
Magnus Carlsen and Hike Marty Rossi are
now a bit of a surprise name it's a
Sprint to the finish for them there's
five rounds remaining in the open
section still plenty of potential banana
skins for them and uh who will stay the
course who will keep that winning streak
going we saw Magnus Carlson win thanks
to a blunder in the last round by
Vincent kymer anti-car Nakamura with
that fantastic tactic against Alexander
grishek Mata Rosie and meanwhile he has
played those two guys already so uh
don't write him off he will be uh
banking uh he'll be backing himself even
uh to continue to keep the pace let's
check out uh let's uh see first of all
who else stands in those top 20 remember
35 prizes so all of these players have
plenty to play for thousands even tens
of thousands of dollars on the line but
it's all about the pairings now let's go
to those matchups because we have a
juicy extremely uh mouth-watering
pairing on board one Lawrence carowana
against Carlson again we saw it in the
world rapid Championship we're seeing it
now in the Blitz the punishi against
Mata rossian number two equally imported
and and Drake in Nakamura
Lawrence what catches your eye from
these top matchups well they're all
they're all fantastic mashups Corona
Carlson is is very interesting because
you know for context recently Magnus has
really had a hold over
Fabiano especially in Blitz they played
a big uh tournament on chess.com where
Fabiano in three hours of Blitz didn't
get a single Victory if my facts are
correct he got blown out by Magnus
and um obviously that does not bode well
that being said Fabi has got white he
has got nothing to lose to go for it uh
you know he will he's a very principled
player he will try to find
something to press against Magnus I
think Magnus in this game would be more
than happy to just come away without
losing and the publishing matarosian is
a great spot obviously for Jana punishi
uh with the white pieces
to really put himself in the mix and
Drake and Nakamura is a tough spot for
uh Hikaru Nakamura and draken quality
Blitz player tricky Blitz player and
Drake has got the white pieces
think this is a potential banana skin
spot actually for Hikaru Nakamura Gary
artimi have also again a match we have
to keep an eye on as is duboff Serana
because if there is a decisive Victory
there suddenly either Gary or timmyev
will have 12 and a half
impossible to predict how things are
going to go now uh it's uh it's
anybody's game
yeah especially after the round where
Carlson and Nakamura both lost I think
we've given up with the predictions it's
just uh yeah it's just that stage where
anything is possible and it's just about
who can keep their calm and we do see
the players taking their seats now
napoleonishi against hike matarosian
we'll keep an eye on that one on board
two and uh of course matarasian he's
done very well at beating players around
his own rating but against the very top
dogs against uh Nakamura against Carson
matarus and has faced defeat he has
suffered that so kind of matter uh
change that Trend against Napoleon we
see Carolina waiting for Carlson Magnus
always keeps his opponents waiting
remember he hasn't turned up late since
the first round so we are expecting
Magnus to appear on time but uh yeah you
mentioned it Lawrence in the speed Chess
Championship just a few weeks ago the
score was 22 to four in magnus's favor
zero losses in 26 games
so Carolina
he's going to be praying for a miracle
at this stage surely
uh his Kryptonite now Magnus Carson
there's got to be a mental block there
can he somehow just put that to one side
and strike on the board he does have
white as he mentioned and here we are we
are off
Carolina starts the game with 24 Magnus
losing a few seconds on the clock to
adjust his pieces as we've seen before
every second counts he lost 10 seconds
there Magnus very surprising remember he
lost on time to napomnishi uh earlier
today but we see no Berlin Wall this
time it's a different variant a
different variation of the Roy Lopez
Spanish opening and what will Magnus go
for will he go for the martial attack
that is something he's employed
throughout the past few years in crunch
games
Fabi playing Bishop D2 in this last move
this was the move he Peyton patented
himself and uh he made fashionable right
Lawrence it looks very interesting white
fish one D2
yeah the idea is he's controlling the A5
Square so that the Knight
um excuse me so that the Knight can't
can't come to A5 and and capture this
bishop
and Mainline Theory or at least it looks
that way judging by the speed with which
both players are playing Fabiano he
still has more time than he started the
game with and we're almost at move 20.
wow uh blistering Breakneck speed here
by both players we've seen a bunch of
exchanges a set of knights a set of
Bishops and a set of Pawns have left the
board white has an open a file not too
much to do with it right now but uh yeah
it's Magnus looking solid I'm a bit
surprised I've got to say I'm surprised
Magnus is playing this kind of
risk-averse approach he just wants to
knuckle down equalizer's black
especially with the context of that
victory in the speed Chess Championship
a few weeks ago where Magnus won a lot
of games by playing provocative chess by
playing unorthodox chess this is very
classical which suits Fabby right down
to the ground
so um early days still yeah D5 on break
by black looks like he's equalized or
almost equalized here Magnus Carlson
Queen E2 D5 played yeah I think once you
get in D5 here is Magnus if you're able
to do it properly and queen E4 yeah I
think Fabi has got close to nothing here
I think you can trade Queens uh which he
does he's gonna take with the pawn
and yeah this is just dead equal
basically uh Magnus Rook C6 love this
move
uh he wants to provoke fabians playing
C3 which would then weaken uh especially
the D3 Square played by Fabiano now this
D3 square is weak long term the nylon G6
can always find its way back F6 love
this move as well
uh just uh supporting the center and
giving the Knight the freedom to now
make its way back it can find a root
back f8 E6 C5 into D3 or B3 to weak
white squares so uh you know a move like
Bishop E7 here will be played
uh at some point I know he went for
before even better trying to create
weakness okay it's still very very level
objectively speaking but Magnus will not
be unhappy
yeah and I mentioned a few moments ago
that uh Fabiano would be very happy with
the outcome of the opening however with
the departure of the queens now we are
up uh Magnus Carlson's alley in his
comfort zone suddenly the black king
will approach the center as you said
Lawrence now black is re-routing his
Knight which was a bit uh futile on the
G6 Square he's going to bring that
towards the queen side and still
balanced still totally level but it's a
Magnus Carlson type of grind he's famous
for using the Magnus effect to outwit
his opponents in this type of simplified
end game and uh I wouldn't back I
wouldn't kind of count against Magnus at
least exerting some pressure I think
Fabi still has this well under control
but look at this a bishop exchange
suddenly white B2 Pawn would be weak
Black's Rooks arguably more active than
white thrux and uh yeah everything else
being balanced maybe some questions to
answer for Fabiano and remember all the
while as long as this game continues the
ghosts of all of those defeats just a
few weeks ago
they will be haunting him I'll be honor
and uh he started to tank a bit on the
clock
only a 20-second disadvantage they're
not significant yet but if Abby can't
speed up can't keep the pace Magnus will
be in Dreamland interesting strategy by
Magnus not going all out for the win
from the start just calming things down
making sure he survives the opening a
middle game and uh in the same game
phase the favorite
okay Rooks off the board now Bishop's
off the board Magnus creating threats
still either black will force the white
Rook to go passive as has just happened
or he would have forced a weakness in
Carolina's Pawn structure
I've got to say this looks very very
level to me but Magnus has the better
side of the draw if indeed it is held by
Fabiano look at this threats now to the
White Knight all good questions which
direction do you go he goes forward like
we'll just sit on the second rank
Lawrence maybe some threats against the
white Pawn structure this black Rook is
extremely strong on the second rank
yeah I'm not loving the spot at all for
Fabiano uh the Knight is coming to C5 on
the next move it's gonna hit this pawn
and then it can come into D3 uh all of
Black's pieces are active whites are not
doing very much
so I am not optimistic about Fabiano's
chances here whatsoever he's gone rugby
one because he wants to get active
um I think this is good
uh Ploy in general
uh
but Magnus Magnus can play Rook C2 here
he'll play Knight C5 for both moose
would have threatened the pawn he
chooses to play Knight C5 attacking
white E Pawn I don't see that active a
way to defend this Pawn now you can play
a move like Rook D2 for example to try
and trade off Rooks if there's a rook
exchange uh white would defend the pawn
but I can simply play Rook A4 in a
situation like that this would be
holdable for white but move like you're
okay for you win a pawn you attack the
White Knight you attack the white Pawn
in the center I think we'll see this on
the board Fabiano might be dropping a
pawn and a minute down suddenly on the
clock
is how Magnus does it he's just so calm
so calculated in his efforts to press
the advantage at least White's Rook can
go active now I think that's what
Fabiano will be itching to do wanting to
do but uh yeah Magnus he's done nothing
at all he's done nothing special but
Fabiano is starting to collapse
it's just a Magnus type of position
there we go Rook D7 at least one piece
is active and the King coming now
black can take a second Pawn but if
Black's Knight takes the F2 Pawn or the
C3 pawn it would be on a great circuit
anymore I think Fabian has found the
only way maybe uh to survive this one at
least the most active principled way
nice defense
yeah I think Fabby fair play to Fabi
getting active with his King getting
acted with this rug when you're on the
back foot you can't remain passive when
your material down you can't remain
passive and Fabi has gone active in
Magnus understanding there is some
issues now because this Knight is coming
into F5 very quickly and all of a sudden
Fabiano's got legitimate counter play
against black
and Magnus not able to
find a way just yet
he decides to attack on F2 which is a
very surprising decision to me
takes one of two Knight F5 and he takes
on H3 Rook G7 and now he's going to be
able to mop up and I think Fabi is now
big favorite to hold the draw here
yep certainly Magnus is still a pawn
ahead he has a three versus two Pawn
advantage that black knight is going to
re-root itself via G5 but look how
powerful White's Knight is on the F5
Square it's not just the middle games
that white uh White Knights on F5 are
strong it's also in the end game
evidently but Fabi down to 10 seconds
the clock could still play a big factor
he still has to be accurate he can't
relax his path to a draw will rely on
maybe a favorable trade at the right
moment going into a nighting game or
rocking game when he can swap off uh all
of the remaining pawns but oh I'm not
sure I like this too much from Fabiano
the White Knight on D6 what is it doing
there it's very unclear it's purpose uh
there we go he corrects his mistake he
goes back to F5 and Magnus creating some
threats activating his King finally and
this is the critical moment has Magnus
blunded into a draw Laurence suddenly
what The Black Keys hit the checks
yeah the king is tied to his Knight and
oh yeah suddenly if you take the White
Knight it's a dead draw uh Magnus
doesn't acquiesce to that draw he's
gonna grab some pawns instead I was
gonna say oh wow from behind this is
genius
it could indeed be genius
okay Fabiano oh did he push G4 he wanted
to push G4 but Fabiana he missed the
moment and he wrote the science oh my
goodness me
Lawrence I think he had the draw if he
played G4 just a moment before I'm not
entirely sure but
he just allowed his Knight to be trapped
Magnus was two pawns up Magnus takes the
win let's check out some other games if
they are still ongoing
it has happened on the other top boards
well this is incredible Hikaru has
beaten and drakin as well which is a
phenomenal result for your car in yeah
no problem she did not
Bates hike montserosian
so that actually means
that the status quo has been restored
Nakamura Carlson now leading together on
13 out of 17 Marta rosian in just half
Point behind and it looks as though
Serana is actually going to beat dubov
with the black pieces
yeah well we saw
the results flying in that we will recap
those shortly but yeah it's those two
giants again Lawrence they just bring
out the best in each other Nakamura
Carlson both pushing each other to the
maximum to try and win their games here
we see a battle ongoing we can't see the
players faces
okay this is Richard Rapport uh I
believe playing with the white pieces uh
Richard Rapport against Dennis lazovic a
youngster uh the blitz phenomenon and
white here looks to be doing very very
well Black's King is so far away from
the action we see a trade of Pawns can
black hole though maybe black can defend
I also because yeah the black king might
be cut off but White's King and Rook
alone can they hunt down that black H
Pawn I'm not so sure they can report
visibly struggling to find a winning
idea here black is just gonna wait like
has the ideal defensive setup and as
soon as White's King advances it will
just get checked back by the black Rook
Miracle saved by Dennis lazovic it
appears in reports after the difficult
start of the day we saw against Magnus
and Hikaru struggling to come back
struggling to get on that winning streak
and yeah check position repeating itself
Lawrence this one looks like a fortress
looks like a drum
does look like a draw don't see any way
for a report
to really mix things up here
great draw if lazovic holds it I just
don't see a way to to make progress here
and reports with five seconds on the
clock he's not uh it's not his favorite
format the blitz section so uh I don't
think he'll be trying to push this one
too hard he won't want to lose on time
okay he moves his King forward you can
tell by White's hand gestures here he
doesn't really believe in the draw and
he pushes his Pawn forward with a
drawther there we go a handshake
well done Dennis lazovic for holding
that position
it's getting tense I feel the tension
still some games going on we've got
feather save here against David Anton El
Nino El Nino in big trouble and in your
toast
might be a time to resign
we're not surviving this the king's
gonna come to C6
Rook will come to support the Rook will
block the checks
simple end game white King has plenty of
squares to hide uh behind it so
important we see the handshake as
Checkmate was incoming with White's two
extra pawns there uh big win for fedisev
who's been up amongst it for a long time
but slipped back slightly David Anton
seeing his chances
really damaged by that defeat and uh we
see the playing hall now how many games
are still going on we still see a couple
of crowds in the far Corner maybe that's
just around the pairings okay we do have
another game uh let's try and get
cameras on this one if we can it looks
like uh vidit against ngoyen uh as
Grandmaster from the Czech Republic and
a draw has just been agreed it looks
like white there was pressing but it
saves a difficult rook and game
uh vidit who was amongst the leaders
yesterday uh falling back a bit over the
last few rounds and both players smiling
discussing the game that's nice to see
yep and in the women's section breaking
news
has done the uh something that uh
everybody else has failed to do which is
beat Paulina shuvalova today uh
incredible victory for castenyuk
she will ever despite losing this still
a full point clear of the field but
suddenly Sarah kadam castinia ubisara
Survivor who had a fantastic result
beating tan dronji with the black pieces
are only a point of
with a few games left three rounds left
shovel over with a point
a distance but what a blow that is had
she won that game
shuvalova would basically have this
tournament in the bag two points clear
with three rounds to go
should only need 50 but now she's got
all the work to do still
um wow just uh the drama continues and
continues we're gonna take another
customary quick break we'll be back in a
few minutes to unpack what just happened
and look forward to round 18
of this phenomenal event
get our breath see you soon
now you can use gifts from the biggest
chest stars on all your favorite
platforms just search chess.com and your
favorite chess star on Discord Twitter
WhatsApp and more to find hundreds of
gifts from chess.com's biggest broadcast
and events nepo Donya Bobby Anna's and
even me Danny try it today
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and welcome back to the coverage of the
world Blitz championships it does look
like we have some controversy during the
break there we see a debate I'm not
exactly sure what's going on Ahmed ugly
there with the white pieces and his
young opponent from Kazakhstan they have
called the Arbiters I think his opponent
here with black is complaining has there
been an incident of touch move maybe has
there been something with the clock we
do see Nikolai averan here he is the
player with the black pieces he's
complaining and uh I feel sorry for him
here because there are reporters
sticking the cameras in his face uh I
think this is the main Norwegian Channel
nrk and uh of course the chief Arbiters
trying to resolve attention Lawrence
let's speculate what do you think is
going on it looks like a balanced
position on the board at least
yeah I have absolutely no idea actually
but Ahmed adley uh in the meantime using
his time to calculate which is uh you
know I don't know how I feel about that
I feel as though you know when there's a
dispute both players should perhaps be
away from the board but Ahmed ugly
there's nothing again in the rules at
least uh you know we're saying that you
can't uh calculate in the position
um
I'm I'm not so sure actually I remember
Arbiters once told me at a big event
that players had to step away from the
board while they were making a decision
on any
um any complaints and yeah it does feel
like uh the Arbiters have made a
decision it feels like maybe they're
giving black two extra minutes so
something has happened Ahmed ugly with
white hair must have broken some rule or
maybe made an illegal move by accident
or maybe touched a piece and either way
black is being rewarded with extra time
that tends to be how things work when
one side has made an illegal move for
example and we will get the game going
can the players refocus uh can Ahmed
ugly former World Junior champion from
Egypt against his young opponent can he
refocus can he save the game artem uskov
who plays under the fide flag is the
player with black and okay two seconds
against six seconds it looks like he
didn't get any any extra time they just
reset the clocks and
oh well okay what is happening here two
seconds for white he's up against up
against the clock can he physically make
a move in two seconds that's the
question once they restart
the opposition looks terrible
for ugly just out just optically the
position looks toast from White doesn't
it how does adley ever survive this
position
I'm not sure with best play it feels
like he might be okay but yeah like you
said Lawrence white is the one defending
white is on the brink here black has
some very strong pawns but the arbit is
struggling to kind of satisfy uh Black's
demands here will we see the game
continue there have been previous
incidents in the tournament there was an
incident between uh vladislav kovalov
and a young player from Kazakhstan where
he also complained and they restarted
the clocks when black had one second
left black couldn't finish the move in
time so there have been
certain moments there always are in
Blitz tournaments that's kind of divide
opinion
but uh yeah I'm hoping to get this one
restarted I think the players at the top
end of the table as well waiting for the
pairings they will be feeling impatient
what will happen here will we see a
resolution
I kind of want to see the game continue
this is the current position Lawrence
and as the digital board shows Ahmed
ugly with white played the move B3
but what happened there why were the
clock stopped what is black complaining
about what do we think Lawrence B3 a
good move feels like black there can
simply play King B4 going towards those
white pawns picking off those remaining
white pawns maybe winning the game
well maybe the white has to just uh
after something like King before Play
Bishop B5 except that this Pawn is going
to go and then just try and hold here
Knight F5 or Knight E4 I don't know
and pray to the gods it's not pleasant
though
it's very unpleasant and the clocks are
about to restart B3 will be the move
Ahmed oddly plays it instantly and okay
King B4 Bishop C4 but Ahmed ugly has
calculated this in the break now Rook G2
looks extremely strong here for black
and now H3 H3 looks strong
this will be a draw
some gamesmanship there potentially from
Ahmed Ali but he does save the game and
disappointment for the youngster with
the black pieces
the object is saying okay enough
yeah they want to disperse the crowd
here too much controversy already this
is why we love Blitz right Lawrence
there's always something going on no
matter what it is I love it I love it
yep
and that of course will be the last game
of that round the pairings will be
getting generated
any second now uh let's take a another
look at this playing Hall see who is
around who is having a good old chat
whilst this is going on
uh let's see here who have we got
see if we can name some names
he's young guys these are all sort of
future Grand Masters are all going to be
26.50 in the next two years or three
years no idea who any of them are
they're just all extremely strong
they're playing the Roblox championships
they will be real fin arms
who else have we got there well
we all we do have the wheel bearings
okay David take us through
yeah so let's check out what's been
happening in the women's tournament you
mentioned some of the results a bit
earlier so let's go to the standings
um if we can and oh let's go to the
matchups even better so we do have
shrivolova as we mentioned still with
one point lead at the top despite
falling to defeat in the previous round
can she recover that is the question
still three rounds to go as you
mentioned Lawrence one point lead is
significant but if you can't recover
from a defeat suddenly things spiral out
of control arabice from Georgia is the
one tasked with taking her down not
gonna be easy that one Anything Could
Happen of course both players on form
and Sarah Carter on board two winning
after a defeating the earlier round she
faces tanzong Yi who's aiming for the
double aiming for another world title
after her success in the women's
rapperton or three equally equally
exciting uh it's kostenic the chess
queen against
the champion from 2021 in the blitz
format so we are focusing our attentions
there but don't be surprised if Stefan
stefanova lagno adelka canaru harika a
bunch of players of nine and a half do
start to climb the table as we mentioned
there's a bunch of prizes I think
there's 15 or so prizes in the women's
tournament so still all to play for uh
shrivel over all eyes on her though with
the pink hair in this
crucial 15th round
I think this is a great parent for sure
whatever
she has played a bunch of the other top
players uh Mary Arabic is a good player
don't get me wrong but uh this is a
great bounce back spot for shovel over
and if she wins she's really getting
close to to Victory
um
anything but a victory is actually not
great for sugar lover because
suddenly if there's a decisive result on
either boards to all three
uh they're half a point behind and you
start to feel the pressure
so shovel over absolutely has to go with
it for it with the black pieces here
uh is is having a tough time and as
Dillman says gurina was a clear leader
now she's so far off the pace four tough
losses in a row I mentioned this
various times throughout the broadcast
Valencia gunina is a momentum player she
can win six in a row but then she can
lose the next four and it's it's it's
really sad to see that after just doing
so well all of a sudden she's lost four
in a row
she's lost against azerbai ever Sarah
cardamom hampi Canary and antonetta
stefanova
putting her out of the race she is now
floating around 16th position
uh absolutely gutted for her hopefully
she she finds some strength though and
finish as well
yeah and we are still awaiting the
match-ups the pairings for the open
section as the final results are
confirmed there I think still some
complaints going on to the Arbiter in
that section so we're guaranteed a bit
of a a bit of a wait now before the next
round kicks off let's take another short
break we'll be back with you in a couple
of minutes to review all the pairings
and start getting pumped start again
hyped for these crucial final rounds
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
chess championships uh we are getting to
the business end of today's action and
to the end of the tournament really
because in the women's section only
three rounds to go uh rounds 15 16 and
17 in the open section we've got four
rounds to go and the pairings are just
coming out and we've got a pretty
unbelievable pairing on board one David
take take our listeners through it
yeah a huge surprise actually the uh
maybe Underdog of the tournament so far
madaminov from Uzbekistan he's only an
international Master he's Blitz rating
is only 2300 he faces off against Magnus
Carlson who outrates him by 500 points
you've got to say for Magnus Carlson
this is the dream pairing he's got to
start as a huge huge favorite here and
uh yeah it's very rare at such a late
stage of the tournament to have such a
favorable pairing on paper but madaminov
has beaten Giants such as mama diarov so
far this tournament so let's see if the
underdog can upset Goliath in that game
we do see Serana up against the other
leader Nakamura Nakamura will be
frustrated that Carlson has such a
favorable pairing and nagmura will want
to strike but Serana of course very
strong player from Russia known as a
blitz specialist Mata rosian the Chaser
on 12.5 half the only player half a
point behind uh Carson and Nakamura he
faces artemiev could artemi have played
spoiler and we see other huge pairings
like Duda and the pomichi Nihao sarin
climbing the table up against Anish giri
and uh yeah plenty of exciting parents
but Lawrence the main talking point has
to be Carlson against Madame could we
see the birth of a new star or will
Carson reassert control
yeah I don't know anything about this
guy Madame of we saw him briefly a
little earlier today he's had some
phenomenal individual results he's
beaten a mamijarov blue bomb he's beaten
t-ramp Petrosian
he's beating Daniel dada uh he's beaten
Radley he was a very serious Blitz
player
amongst other top Grand Masters so
great score for him
on 11 and a half playing board one
in the fideo Blitz World Championships
there we can see Serana playing against
Hikaru
Alexei Serrano believe me no slouch
proper proper Blitz player
um can cause problems on his day
so that's not going to be easy and here
we are we here we see the young man
himself
from Uzbekistan uh
he is uh I think 16 years old
so quite the moment for him
remember Lawrence last year in the world
rapid Championship we also saw a
breakout start from Uzbekistan we saw
nordeback Abdul sotorov storm through
beat Magnus Carson and win the world
title so could lightning strike two
years in a row another Prodigy from that
great nation of Uzbekistan and okay we
see the game begin very confident play
so far from the 16 year old eyeing up
his opponent there we see Magnus adopt a
very classical setup here of fianchetto
against grinfeld and uh this shows how
much respect Magnus has for his young
opponent Magnus is playing proper
opening serious openings and two choices
here Magnus brings out his night he
could also have advanced in the center
matamine of looking very confident in
the early stages I don't know too much
about him myself uh either Lawrence I've
got to say but from the games I have
seen throughout the rapid and Blitz
looks very strong in the opening this
young player I guess all Blitz
Specialists do have the foundation of
being strong in the early phase of the
game Magnus giving his opponent quite
significant time odds here spending half
a minute up to the stage and it's still
very well known territory white brings
his night out to C3 it's still May 9
Theory and uh in this position white has
two main options either you push forward
with the e or D Pawns and uh we're
waiting for the electronic board to
catch up with the camera we're looking
at Magnus twirling a piece there
fiddling are the nerves kicking in he's
been in this situation so many times
before uh the Norwegian but Lawrence
he's playing so slowly Magnus what is
happening here the clock
I think he's a bit out of book actually
I just think it's been ages since he's
looked at this particular line
Bishop F4 played Knight D4 Knight E4 and
E5 whereas madaminov is clearly well in
book and Mike this has to be a little
bit careful here
yeah he's going actually for just an
inferior position just admitting he's
slightly worse saying okay I was kind of
just bluffing this opening I haven't
looked at it for a while
and now I'm going to take the slightly
worse position against you young man and
uh you know two Bishops no issues with
this position you can put the push when
she serve and you can play rookie eight
you can play Queen E7
you can play all kinds of moves 45
seconds up on the clock dream start for
madame
yeah he could not have wished for a
better position a better situation
against the world champion uh Madame of
great opening you're right Magnus maybe
not familiar with the nuances I think
white should have planted his Knight on
C6 earlier there were some tactics there
very well known position but look at the
speed look at the confidence from Black
Magnus just had to contort himself play
some really weird ugly moves of Rook D3
what is The Rook doing on that square
looks like a tactical Target for blacks
Bishops I mean while Magnus starts to
kick back attacking blacks Bishop on G4
forcing it back home but you can happily
Retreat that piece bring it back to C8
put it out the way keep the two Bishops
for later and look how composed he uh he
is right now Madame of not flinching at
all and he takes away
also a very ambitious about five I love
this idea as well he's trading now
creating this isolated past Pawn
isolated uh sorry Queens pool Rook d8
you take black here all day surely
he's yeah he's at least equal maybe even
better as you say Loris with the
advantage of the better Pawn structure
you've got to keep Pace on the clock
Magnus has sped up quite a lot Magnus
still very solid but madamina of going
on the attack not afraid to pounce Queen
B4 attacking the D4 Pawn with the rook
and is Black's Queen gonna dive even
further in Queen B3 white has a lot of
weaknesses
I think Magnus might well be facing an
upset in this game Black's Knight is
coming into C4 Black's piece is all
Super Active
Norwegian here under pressure If This
Were a classical game you would say he's
significantly worse Black is in the
driver's seat okay the black Bishop goes
back maybe the first sign of some nerves
I think there were Superior moves there
uh maybe the bishop could have sat on E6
for example and Magnus is bringing the
knight in so black just needs to keep
control keep steady on the clock Don't
Panic it's only one attacking piece
White Knight and queen however are
headed towards that black king so you
have to be slightly wary and Magnus okay
he's starting to unravel so no longer
necessarily an inferior position for
white black queen needs to rejoin her
Army at some point she's a bit offside
black king a bit vulnerable and look at
Madame he lent back he realizes the
nerves are getting to him
okay he recomposes himself and Retreats
Queen B6 looks good looks healthy and uh
okay still a positional battle he
avoided any immediate Knockouts though
uh the black King's safe for now I like
how he positioned his Knight on D5
stopping any checks
it's uh Hey Magnus is Magnus Ferraris
and queen G5 active play momentum
changing still level but can he cope
with the changes what do you think
Lawrence Madame suddenly it doesn't look
as good anymore his position look at the
White Queen at night they've improved
enormously Black's position has worsened
over the last four or five turns
it has but uh you know fair play to
Madame of he's he's staying in there
he's staying cool as possible he's
staying as cool as possible
uh but definitely uh things have turned
in Magnus favor now I think he's going
to take on default now he goes 93
also movement keeping the tension
oh and we see the position repeat itself
Magnus took his Knight back to D3 Bishop
B6 95 a little dance with the Knight and
Bishop there we surely won't see Magnus
acquiesce to a draw against someone 500
points rated lower than him uh of course
madaminov underrated much stronger than
that but
Magnus he knows that Nakamura is going
to be racing ahead Nakamura will be
racking up the winds towards the back
end of this tournament and he's got to
keep Pace thinking for 30 seconds now
Magnus he's Frozen he's got to find a
move and both both of them twiddling
with their pawns here
and uh
okay we're being told that Nakamura is
seriously worse in his game Magnus would
be aware of that however Magnus is
purely focusing on his own board what a
turn up that would be if Magnus and
Nakamura both lose in the same round
again so meanwhile Magnus didn't go for
the repetition he didn't go for the draw
just keeping the tension 30 seconds
against one minute though you've got to
say Black's position looking good yet
again he's stabilized madaminov it was
great for him in the opening a few
patchy moves here and there but he's
looking strong again and Magnus
Lawrence he's just too slow he's got to
speak yeah he's already lost some time
once today he's he's had a bit of a
brain freeze here Magnus this is quite
unbelievable because just doesn't tend
to happen with Magnus and madamina fair
play to him Magnus really down on the
clock
uh
uh there might be a full trade here
Magnus might have gotten lucky but is he
still slightly worse possibly
B2 Pawn is going to have lately 7 rugby
two for example
rookie one she can really do much better
over D7
oh a bit of negativity there from the
youngster he could have at least drawn
if he'd played Rook D2 kept the Rooks on
the board suddenly trading off when
White's King is actually closer to the
center than blacks it doesn't look that
way but White's King has a clear path in
on the dark squares Black's King has
been caged by magnus's last few moves
should still be a draw of course but can
he hold his Nerf Madame I think he's
done a good job there centralizing his
King and okay Magnus has to take a step
back Lawrence this surely is headed
towards a draw now big shock and a great
result for madame
should be a draw but magna's still only
with 10 seconds can Madame of do
something completely unexpected
the answer is probably not
Magnus managing to stabilize now and I
mean I'm putting all of his pawns on
light squares don't know about that
yeah very committed to say it very
committed
shows nerves matter mean of yes he's
found a good home for the black Bishop
but his pawns are targets long term look
out for Magnus working Batman game magic
yet again look at this he's trying to
zuk Swang black he's trying to say okay
you're Frozen those black pawns now not
on the right color complex and Magnus is
coming across with his King suddenly all
three results possible and I do think
Madame needs to start exchanging needs
to start swapping off pawns as quickly
as possible Maybe
the pawn to B4 push trade off I don't
mean off from these expensive now oh
he's been forced to take a step back
white king dominates now
zuk Swang is coming Lawrence suddenly
the black Bishop is totally frozen
Magnus
if he grinds this one out I mean what a
turn that would be a decisive
potentially moment in the tournament
uh yeah he's just put his pawns on light
squares don't put the pawns on the same
color as your Bishop this was an easy
draw at least for Madame but now
suddenly he's on the back foot and we
see the evaluation bar slightly reacting
so not significant still should be a
draw but uh yeah the white pawns can
never be touched on Happily on dark
squares
end game grind end game magic from
Magnus Carlson maybe and he starting the
race okay he's going after the black
pawns who is leading in this race
matamino has lost control though looking
nervous on the clock it's level again
and black supports of whoa Magnus
dropping pieces as well Black's pawns
have fallen
those two white pawns the A and B pawns
surely gonna decide this game this is
where experience plays a factor right
Lawrence
oh Bishop B3 class move there by Magnus
as well but I mean of hitting the pawn
in frustration what an unfortunate turn
of events madaminov is going to lose
this game
because of way too fast here
and the King can even come over F4
that's a lovely movie yeah and we see
the handshake and we Lawrence Magnus
takes the win we have to go over
immediately to Hikaru Nakamura because
this one looks over black is three pawns
down it's a queen of three against just
a bear Queen and uh yeah Hikaru is
falling to defeat here Serana playing
the role of spoiler he is going to do
Magnus Carlsen a huge favor you have to
be slightly careful of stalemate ideas
Black's King in the corner hoping
praying that Serana gets a bit nervous
here he is nervous he's allowing one
Pawn to drop but this should be
sufficient should be a simple process of
preventing the checks as soon as the
tracks dry up this one will end Lawrence
are we seeing the decisive round the
turning point of this whole tournament
I think this was a massive decisive
moment Nakamura losing Hikaru Magnus
Carlsen winning especially in the
fashion he did he got extremely lucky to
win that game and as I said
yep
when luck shines
and Hikaru Nakamura
stumbling yet again at the critical
moment
his career has been glorious but that
title ever so evasive just can't seem to
just finish the job it was a point clear
starting today and now he is a whole
point back from Magnus Carlson and we've
not even we've barely played half the
games it's been a catastrophic day
for Hikaru Nakamura Magnus Carlsen with
a touch of luck from Kaiser herself
he's now on 14 points Nakamura
matarosian on 13. yank yourself Duda
beats yeah and the publishing that
almost ends Yanda Palmer she's hopes
he's two points adrift
Daniel dubov beating Min Lee but feels
as though those on 12 and a half just
too far behind
anyways a point behind Magnus with three
rounds to go it doesn't look good it's
uh it's been a brutal day for Nakamura
especially
but remember Lawrence we have been here
before Marcus was one point clear with
three rounds to go in the rapid section
and uh he blundered there he let it slip
and players caught up so it's not over
it is heartbreaking for Nakamura I think
at this point we all want to see him win
the world Blitz title he deserves at
least one of those he's one of the best
players in the world in place for sure
but it's not gonna be easy for him
meanwhile we see a Time scramble between
Andre essepenko and I think this is
vacidov from Uzbekistan a member of the
gold medal winning Uzbek team there but
it does end and what is the result it
looks like a draw and there we go a draw
confirmed between these two very strong
young Grandmasters uh yeah there's just
so much action everywhere we wish we
could cover all of them but Lawrence
looks like those were some of the final
games of this round like you said three
games left in the open section still a
bit of time and two games left in the
women's
yeah and uh
incredibly uh I will uh just uh mention
that we were focusing on uh on the the
game of Ahmed adley before
um and the controversy was that
apparently he was disturbed by the
friends of his 12 year old opponent and
the Arbiter decided to give adley two
extra seconds because they actually lost
on time as a result of the disturbance
and he was given the two seconds the
game ended into draw uh that's
unconfirmed but still worth pointing out
who do we have here
wow we have two very very young players
uh we'll try and find out their identity
soon I must admit I'm not too familiar
with them uh it's a queen end game we've
seen many Queen end games this round and
white has an extra Pawn but this should
be a draw why its pawns aren't past this
is going to be a bunch of checks it's
going to be very hard for the white king
to hide and okay locking up the pawn
structure like this really shouldn't
help white too much I think black can
simply Retreat the queen to a safe
square and that should be that and uh
black skin also in the corner is a good
defensive strategy we should mention in
these end games there's always going to
be still Matrix the only thing not to do
for black is to allow a queen Exchange
in the wrong way or to blunder your
remaining Pawn but I think we will see a
draw in this game we could see either
draw any moment now I think black can
confirm this with a bunch of accurate
checks you should always check on the
diagonal in Queen games in Queen end
games if you can
those are often the most effective and
there we go this does prevent the white
king from coming in towards the black
king on the G6 Square
this one we do see a handshake and a
draw the Arbiter thank you to the
Arbiter for blocking no we don't see a
drawer Lawrence did one of those guys
lose on time it looks as though it won't
break time off
that's a tough pill to swallow he was a
he was a pawn up okay the position was
objectively a draw but still to lose
that is heartbreaking
goodness me what a round
in intense rounds of Blitz sorry
Lawrence yeah we didn't talk about the
women's section massive massive news
that Arab it's a held shovel over to
draw the tangjong ji beating Sarah kadam
and asubai beating costenia means that
shuvalova is half a point clear of
tanjongji and bibisara
meaning that with two rounds to go there
still Paulina shuvalova has work to do
she is only half a point clear
um and
well she's uh she's gonna have nerves of
Steel to to take this one home she's
been leading from the front for a long
long time she's been up there
she deserves her shot but is tan drumsy
gonna do the double is bibisara forever
going to retain her title the next round
is gonna be absolutely crucial of course
what we're going to do is we're going to
be back with the pairings for the next
round don't go anywhere things get super
hot in the feed a worldless
championships see you in a few minutes
life is full of exciting events but it
is our first impressions that we
remember best your first diploma
[Applause]
your first job in a big company
full emotions from the first date the
first expensive things you bought when
you got your first paycheck and your
first Investments with freedom broker
Freedom broker look at your favorite
brands from A New Perspective
[Music]
thank you
all right
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everybody to live coverage
of the 2022 feed a world Rich
championships and World women's glitch
championships
uh we are at a critical stage in the
proceedings it's an old day it's the
championship rounds coming up before I
talk a little bit more about what has
been going on I do want to remind you
guys that uh it's not too late to have
your say in the 2022 chess.com Awards
with categories like Game of the Year
Player of the Year creator of the year
make sure you vote type in exclamation
mark Awards to find out more information
and to vote now
um wow I mean what are what a few rounds
we've had uh I think uh it's a good
moment for me to bring in the real start
of this show the man the myth the legend
uh one of my favorite people on the
planet
and uh
pretty good chess player in his own
right Grand Master David Howe David
you're too kind Lords um I've got a true
trumpet as well and
I want to mention
um the chess.com Awards uh I've got to
do a self plug there there is a category
commentator of the year and I'm being
told that even my own mother didn't vote
for me she voted for someone else so I
need all of you viewers sir you know
what to do to go over there uh
exclamation mark Awards sorry Lawrence I
couldn't resist no it's it's fantastic
go and vote for David Howe uh please do
he's been phenomenal this year on the
meltwater championship tour now we had a
really really crucial round just now
let's go over the key moments David
minus Carlson meeting madaminov but he
struggled to do so and what more
importantly for him
I guess or rather more
uh uh
positively for him his closest rival
Hikaru Nakamura has has started to
really falter
as the championship rounds approach
that's right uh that was a crucial it
all swung in just the space of a few
moves Magnus had a dead drawn end game
against madaminov but madaminov maybe
with a lack of experience there tried to
force the issue and Magnus took
advantage just as the at the same time
as that was happening Nakamura his
position all fell apart so that is the
type of small margins that we experience
and that often decide these big titles
however Magnus it's not going to be easy
the run-in for him some tough pairings
ahead and we all know Nakamura is
certainly capable of going on a winning
streak we see uh there were a few
players chasing Magnus the point is the
gap is one point now and uh we see the
top 20 in the standings we will check in
a bit later on how that settles down 35
prices available in the open but let's
go to the matchups and it's the Slayer
of Nakamura it's Alexei Serrano who gets
his shot at Magnus Carlson he's still a
bit behind he's still one and a half off
one and a half points off the lead but
could he do the double letters could
Serana take down Carson as well do
Nakamura a favor this time
Carlson certainly won't be
underestimating his opponent there if
you do that against Mata rosian as well
and Nakamura has to beat shimanov in
order to try and catch up and uh we'll
also be told in the future chats that
Serana started the tournament with three
points out of eight he's a man informed
he's on a hot streak
yeah no serran has come back nicely I
think this is a slightly odd and
difficult pairing for Magnus actually
Serana is a very very strong Blitz
player and clearly is a confidence
player as well uh to get to this score
after starting so poorly is very very
impressive he's got the white pieces
Magnus has not shown his best today uh
his last game against Madame he was
worse with white out of the opening
worse in some middle games he's been uh
he was dead lost against Richard Rapport
so Carlson is getting all The Strokes of
luck he could possibly ask for but if he
comes up against
um a strong Grand Master and experienced
Grandmaster if he gets presented if
sorry if that Grandmaster gets presented
with the same sorts of opportunities I
do fear that that is going to be
converted this is a critical game for
Magnus Carlson uh a draw is fine for him
the win is obviously superb a loss just
blows open the field and all of a sudden
it's anybody's tournament yet again a
massive round for Hikaru Nakamura has to
beat Shimano just know ifs or buts this
is a must win situation he needs to get
back on the horse he's had a dreadful
day so far he has yet to win a game
uh oh sorry I pick up on that's not
completely true that's uh that's a
that's a true truly false he has beaten
Bristol and andrekin I beg your pardon
but he's suffered two brutal losses
against artemiev and Serana which have
really hindered his chances so this is a
must-win situation for Hikaru and um you
know somebody like Marta Rosie and
Blaine do that doodle will go all in
against Master Rose in here no question
also closed the gap
we'll soon find out
yeah we will find out meanwhile let's go
to the standings in the women's
tournament where the chase is on uh we
do know that uh Paulina shuvalova she's
been leading as you mentioned Lawrence
from the start she burst out into the
lead and she's been there ever since
however tanzong Yi and bibrasara bayeva
they are now only half a point behind
it's two games to go but just a draw by
shovel over and suddenly we might see
players catch up we might even see
another playoff we saw a playoff in the
women's rapid World Championship could
we see lightning strike twice uh this is
the top of the table with two players
chasing chival over a few players a
point behind let's go to those big
matchups the key matchups and you don't
win World titles by uh taking it easy
you don't get there against weak
opposition she's playing one of the
strongest women in the world hampi
coneru who's uh won a few games over the
last few rounds only one point behind
humpy could even catch up with
shrivolova if she takes the point in
this next game and tanzong Yi faces
former world champion uh antoinetta
stefanova I saw by ever meanwhile
against Sarah cardam local fans over in
Kazakhstan will be supporting Asura
bayova's quest to regain her crown and
uh meanwhile let's go to the playing
Hall the players are ready they're
seated they're itching to get going I
know there's going to be a lot of
impatient players in the tournament Hall
especially in the second half of the
table who just want to get their days
done but at the top the stakes are high
tens of thousands of dollars available
in prize money for them here we see Duda
against mati rosian on board two oh it's
looking very calm you've got to say
Lawrence and you mentioned anything
possible in this game do we think anyone
can catch Magnus is Magnus gonna get the
two and a half points from the last
three rounds that he requires to get the
gold
I I think to be honest all everything is
the gods are smiling on Magnus Carlson
at the moment uh that's the bottom line
uh anything he does is being rewarded
play Bad win
uh play normal win
uh hope for your nearest Rivals to not
win that happens I don't know what what
uh pot of gold or leprechaun this guy
found years ago I wish I did the same
that's for sure or is he just a genius
and he makes his own luck
to be fair you don't become multi-time
world champion multi-time rapid
multi-time Blitz by just being lucky
he's the greatest of all time for a
reason
is he gonna complete the trifecta
10 minutes
we have liftoff this would be the third
world title that he holds uh if he can
win his next three games Magnus his fate
is in his own hands meanwhile this game
has started Serrano wanting to play
spoiler yet again after taking down
Nakamura it starts as the Queen's Gambit
declined we see an early exchange of
Pawns I think Serrano employed this
exact uh variation earlier in the
tournament if I'm not mistaken Bishop F4
quite a rare move forcing Magnus to
think at this early stage Magnus brings
his pieces out I've got to say as well
this is what we call the Carlsbad Pawn
structure there's no greater expert in
wheelchair so maybe throughout chess
history than Magnus Carlson in this
structure Serana plays a very ambitious
move on the last turn after Black's
Bishop came out to F5 pushing the port
to F3 not the typical setup that we uh
are accustomed to it does hint at a
potential porn storm if uh if black is
careless here for example White's gonna
throw the G Pawn forward with gain of
time uh gain of time we're gonna throw
the h-born forward Magnus hates his
opponents gaining space Magnus is very
very sensitive to pawn structures he
pushes H5 just to prevent any of those
ideas later on and after a trade of
light squared Bishops Knight A6 bringing
his Knight out aiming to come forward
maybe and attack the queen nope Magnus
Retreats he's just trying to consolidate
he is wary he's ready for an expansion
in the center from White's pawns
Lawrence I've got to say I love serana's
opening Choice really flexible white
Canal choose which side you want to
Castle on depending on your mood
depending on your ambitions
is Magnus here solid enough
oh White's pushing forward with E4
getting shot like this yep like this
take this into while you can no harm
done it takes takes what it's got the
big Center 96 you can just Castle this
is a successful opening for Serato and
this Pawn H5 the problem Magnus has got
is that this makes his uh castling whoa
uh issue serious because he cannot
Castle easily on the king side and then
of course all he does is Castle on the
king side says
I'm not worried but I would be worried
this is a serious weakness why isn't
white just turns better here Bishop B3
okay E1 small improving moves I would go
Rook ae1 here to then put the bishop
back on C1 that would be my ideal setup
get out the way use this f file Target
this pool
let's see and he's gone for E5 that
feels like a very
unnecessarily committal way of playing
but might still be okay 95 would get a
an interesting sort of trans the
structure completely changed now
and the Knight on E6 suddenly becomes a
massive massive blockade I'm not sure I
love it
from White's perspective
everything looked perfect for white it's
very hard to kind of just sit still
acknowledge you've done the hard work
and just slowly maneuver from there and
I think Serana got itchy fingers he
pushed forward with E5 as you say there
or it's changing the pawn structure and
now look at White's Bishop White's
Bishop is not a happy piece it's blocked
by its own pawns that being said Serana
still with very aggressive intentions
plays Knight to G3 attacking that Lone
Ranger out on H5 Magnus would love to
retreat that pawn back where it came
from back to its starting square but
instead he's had to take out time out
defending that and look at Magnus
decision there practically wow the
exchange he knew the attack was scary an
incoming attack against the black king
So Magnus said just take my Rook for
your bishop and Magnus has gone Pawn
hunting with this queen it feels like
this must be fantastic for white now
objectively but still some hurdles to
overcome white Central ports are
dropping Serana allows the capture of
white D4 Pawn uh we'll wait for the
electronic board that to catch up but it
does look like pieces are getting traded
off okay Magnus doesn't take Queens off
still The Exchange up for white Rook for
Bishop and Paul and this I think we
might see another another Victory by
Serana could Magnus be slipping up could
the tournament be thrown right uh right
open again
disaster for Magnus Carlson in this
position today but you know Magnus he's
such a magician is he going to be able
to find a way to hold this
wouldn't surprise me
yeah if the Queens come off Magnus has
targets okay I'm not sure Serana should
have agreed to that exchange of Queens
Oh No rookie one is excellent
very clever Magnus knocking over some
pieces he's touched his Bishop but
there's no safe squares for the bishop
Lawrence the bishop is trapped oh no
that's it he picked up his Bishop there
was nowhere safe to put it so he resigns
wow wow it's over so quickly Serana
crushing Magnus Carlson we've got to say
I think the only move to survival is
actually Knight back to d8 but he'd
already touched his Bishop he'd picked
it up and now the door's been open for
Nakamura and Mata rosian let's go over
to those games here we do see
uh is this
no this is
Duda yes so doodle with white uh let's
try and get a better view of the board
we do see level material but dude it's
in charge look at those white Bishops
great potential blacks Knight very very
loose while Serana Lawrence taking down
Nakamura and Carlson back to back
yeah quite quite incredible stuff
actually
um
quite incredible stuff
[Music]
white is going Pawn hunting you've got
to be slightly careful there's a threat
to trap white Bishop on G3 black is
threatening to play F4 and uh that
Bishop is caged so do you want to allow
that to happen maybe you can get some
compensation there uh or do you trade
off Bishops the problem with trading off
the dark Square Bishops here is that
blacks Knight comes to a better square
and we see Duda tapping his finger there
in frustration he knows he's doing well
but he can't see the killer blow and to
be honest Lawrence I don't think it's so
simple either I think this is much
tougher than the evaluation Bar says in
human terms at least especially in Blitz
and due to time Advantage he was almost
up a minute it's disappeared and he
blocks in his own Bishop that is ugly
but uh maybe it was necessary and white
Rooks and Bishops will still go Pawn
hunting later
temporarily at least he's playing
without that dark Square Bishop on G3
yes he is and uh a big uh Improvement in
Black's position therefore
but still plenty of work to do for
blackbook D5 qg7
okay not to Rosie now Troy's going to go
H5 now that Bishop feels locked for a
very long time it should be five rookies
seven keeping things together
I like how much Rosie is playing
F3
um
at least he has an Escape Route for that
Bishop now the white dark sky Bishop can
re-root itself via F2 a bit later on
meanwhile matarosian going for the
threats there was a threat of pointer C6
forking the white rook and white rip and
the white Bishop hence a retreat by Duda
I've got to say I love totally love what
macharusian's been doing he's locked up
the position and when you have Knights
against Bishops uh here black has the
only Knight in the position just block
things up
a great strategy and
okay Duda very hesitant here under 10
seconds it's going to be a mad Scramble
now he's just moving his Rook back and
forth Duda can't find a plan and Black's
night is coming
okay no motorizing Retreats kind of
repeats the position and uh the status
quo has been maintained this one's so
tense feels like equal with best play
neither side able to find a productive
plan but
anything can still happen in the
scramble Duda oh down to two seconds
we've seen him struggle on the clock in
various games so far this tournament
will that happen again this bishop is
out though his Bishop is out of its
prison on G3 maybe he's the favorite
again yeah Christoph Duda
and B4 going for an oh going for a past
Pawn on the queen side dropping his H
Pawn Lawrence it's anyone's game
anybody's game this apron it's very very
dangerous
uh three seconds for matarosian two
seconds Gotta Move first
we'll see seven check into mezzo
this looks bad now for MATA Rosie it
looks very very bad
um
pinning those white Bishops uh he's
gonna grab one of them but look at this
throwing the pieces around an A7 wow he
allows a new Queen to land on the board
but this is gonna spell disaster Motors
and loses on time as well wow dude uh
his nurse held he took the win Mata
rosian is not going to join Magnus
Carlson in the lead
and breaking news in the women's section
humpy kanuru beats chivalova a
catastrophic couple of rounds for
Paulina who was doing so well
she's lost against a humbly Canary she
lost against the only drug is Murray
Arabic and that means that chances for
players to overtake her including
reigning women's Blitz Champion as if I
ever if she wins her position against
Sarah khadam
and Lawrence we are
yeah sorry we are with another of the
players who could LeapFrog uh the leader
shivolova we're with tanzongi right now
she has white pieces against stefanova
former women's world champion and white
has an extra Bishop Lawrence it's bishop
and two pawns a set of Rooks on the
board as well against uh just two points
okay a trade there white H porn White's
remaining Pawn does promote on a dark
Square which really helps she has a dark
Square Bishop a long grind ahead can
black hold the draw
what do you think Lawrence is gonna get
this win
if so then she is going to be one of the
big favorites uh in the final this is
actually going to go on for some time
guys this is uh this is one of those
games she's gonna win the F Pawn most
likely Bishop D4 there you go F Pawn has
been one then she's actually this is not
even gonna go on for that or she's going
to win the H1 as well this is surely
just hopeless
for until next week
you have to be a bit careful there's a
pin on White's Bishop so you can't get
greedy and grab Black's Pawn on F6 yet
don't play Rook takes Pawn that would
blow the win white king however can
start to enter I think that's the most
active way to play this end game there
we go the king comes in continues its
Journey great technique from tanzon Yi
there's no way that black can eliminate
whites remaining Pawn even if you can
we'll see that dreaded endgame of rook
and Bishop versus Rook which is so
difficult to defend over the board in
Practical terms but uh Stefan over here
there's light on the clock reflecting
there we can't see how much time she has
but it feels like she's playing with
seconds left tanzongi has Consolidated
like you said Lawrence once one Pawn
drops the other will follow shortly and
I think we'll see a cleaning up job from
Tanzania soon she offers a Trader Brooks
that's only possible because the H porn
promotes on a dark square and
sooner rather than later that white king
is coming to pick off Black's Pawn
find some stages of this game great
technique by San Junction cutting the
black king off
you can now move the king to G6 and
Vanessa's gonna go here Bishop G5 now
she wins the pawn and that's enough
to stefanova what a win for 10 John ji
that means that she Leap Frogs shovel
over let's go to the asubai Eva game
playing against Sarah kadam
and hold on I think that game is over
simply it was way of the winning or one
and what that means is we have two new
leaders as if I ever and tanjongji
I said whatever in the lead with one
round to go but it's tanjongji gonna do
the double and win Rapid or is that
somebody ever going to maintain the
title yes we'll come to those standings
shortly we'll update you with all the
results as we head into the final round
of the women's section this is
Christopher you with the white pieces
against Andre essepenko Christopher you
American Prodigy he's got that end game
he's got Rick and Bishop versus Rook we
mentioned it a minute ago no pawns here
so this should be a draw but can Andre
essapenko hold his nerve it's so tough
to defend this one plenty of world-class
Grandmasters have lost this end game but
I think he knows the drawing technique
he needs to keep his King on a safe
Square here he keeps it on the same file
as white king so white king can never
move the white Bishop is pinned this is
a well-known drawing Motif now as soon
as the white king goes one way you go
the other way with the black king and uh
now erecting the second ranked defense
offering a trade of Rooks esipenko from
the Russian School of Chess very
classical player very well educated
player he's clearly spent dozens of
hours analyzing this one he knows
exactly what to do this is very
impressive to defend with 10 seconds
left on the Block Christopher you speed
specialist he looks frustrated the
position has almost repeated itself now
a few times he's running out of winning
ideas look at this again shoulder
checking the king as soon as the white
king goes one way the black king goes
the other way this is going to end in
the draw I can't see Essa panko with his
great technique letting this one slip
uh this could be a battle we'll see for
years to come as well both very very
young of course both still I believe uh
in their teens
and yeah this one will go on for 50
moves I think we'll see Christopher you
abandon his winning attempts soon
and uh yeah Lawrence these two players I
mean they're playing for a lot of money
right uh potentially it could be huge
for their careers if they can get into
those top 35 places get those prizes
or Christopher you he's done well in the
last few days I think he had a tough
start to the tournament but he won't be
able to win this one unfortunately
and yet again the pin we've seen this
position before
is trying something new Christopher you
and look at this Lawrence I'm learning I
must say if anyone wants to learn how to
defend this end game go check out what
Essa panko has been doing repeating the
same pattern over and over again never
in doubt
no extreme brilliant oh yeah brilliant
defense
textbook stuff
yeah and uh I think we all need to catch
our breath because we are in for a hell
of a round uh in the women's section and
two very dramatic games ahead of course
in the open after Magnus Carlson's
defeat
yeah the pack have caught up
okay we're gonna go for a break well
we're gonna go for a break while this
probably ends up in a draw we'll keep
the game on screen and when we come back
in just a few minutes we're going to
talk about what just happened two rounds
to go in the open section the women's
final round and it's all been turned on
its head it's actually quite
extraordinary we'll be right back in
just a few minutes don't go anywhere
just played an exciting game and want to
see if you got a brilliancy or maybe
where you could have improved
chess.com's game review is just a click
away
game review is a fast fun and
instructive guided review of your games
be your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy check out the ebal graph for an
instant overview and scroll down to see
how many great moves best moves blunders
and yes brilliancies you have played
learn from chess.com's coach who gives
move explanations opening statistics and
shows you the best lines of play
with retry mistakes you can get another
shot at finding missed opportunities
try game review today on web iOS or
Android
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
everybody welcome back to chess.com's
coverage of the feed 8 wild Blitz
championships and
it is getting close to crunch time it is
the final round of the women's
tournament about to take place and we
had an incredible last round there we'll
uh detail all of that in a second and in
the open section Magnus Carlsen showing
that he is human gets absolutely crushed
must be said by Alexei serrana
meaning that the open tournament with
two rounds to go is still too close to
call
uh Carlson a half a point lead at the
moment but
revitalized hopes for Nakamura Duda
Serana
David it's been an absolute blast so far
it's been uh a roller coaster these past
few rounds
so much has happened uh perhaps we can
take a look at at another game while we
wait for the pairings
had a nice win against Alexander gristro
yeah maybe we can go through this game
uh there was a very nice finish to it uh
neponishi of course
had a great day fell back slightly but
he's now only one point off the lead so
with two games to go still in with a
theoretical chance of mathematical
chance uh King's Indian one of the main
lines of the king's Indian very dramatic
opening uh very controversial opening in
terms of both sides having opposing
plans still very standard stuff so far
White playing on the queen side black
playing on the king side and naponia she
with this Knight H4 move playing some
very strange ideas but playing on both
sides of the board he was able to break
through with C5 uh Lawrence I guess this
is very thematic stuff yes the night was
kicked back or was it it came into F5
and things opened up in White's favor it
appeared at least in Practical terms
Grisha overextending potentially in the
center and a peace Sacrifice by wow the
evaluation bar doesn't like it the
computer doesn't approve but in human
terms very scary to allow the White
Knight into the E6 square and that
Knight disappeared was replaced by some
very strong past points
but the computer is still saying this
isn't enough so Sasha went seriously
wrong somewhere uh this move Queen E8 is
not liked at all the computer much
refers something like a blockading with
like 97 keeping everything together
Queenie eight big blunder by Sasha
grishtook uh the point being that after
Queen E8 white can now just push uh A5
and just push the a pawn down the board
and basically there's nothing you can do
you just push all the way on Knight C7
Rook C1 attacking it
just won that night
and all just like that it's all she
wrote
uh suddenly
yep
sorry I was just gonna say passports are
there to be pushed and unfortunately in
Blitz that's the hardest thing when the
opponent has a simple plan like pushing
a past Pawn how do you counter that you
need counter play you need really kind
of resolute defense and uh kushuk
couldn't stand the tension grishek of
course down to a few seconds as it as is
his customary style and uh no promise
you too quick too sharp uh maybe we can
also check out the final position of the
Nakamura game Lawrence because Nakamura
was one point behind going into this
round he had a chance to catch Magnus he
didn't expect to slip up maybe from uh
the Norwegian and
we saw a tough game actually from
Nakamura not up to his usual standards
he was on the defending side of a draw
we saw this being the final position
like his upper pawn and shimanov here
could maybe have even tried to press for
more but uh I think both players happy
with the results in the end happy with
the drawer and Nakamura is still half a
point behind
can he make up that deficit uh yeah
Nakamura fans hoping he can just find
the energy it's really been lacking over
the last few rounds
I think this particular uh game is a bit
of a blessing Nakamura because he's a
poem down only shimanov can play for a
win and for Shimano to basically accept
a draw when he also seemingly has more
time on the clock seems a bit strange to
me maybe shimanov with one eye on the
prize fund but he has a pretty risk-free
position I don't get why this would end
in a draw it's great for Hikaru because
he probably saw Serana beating Carlson
and thinks well if I stay within half a
point I still have a chance
so a good round finally for Hikaru
Nakamura
a good round but maybe not the optimal
round he still has to make up half a
point with two games to go and uh I'm
not sure if we're waiting for the
standings the pairing still we do see
the playing Hall there as uh players are
yet to really re-enter yet to start
taking their seats
it looks like we do have the standings
right now with Magnus Carlson still at
the top of the table 14 points after 19
games and he is chased Now by a pack of
three Nakamura Duda and the man of the
moment Alexei Serrano who's on a hot
streak started with three points out of
eight games but has just beaten Nakamura
and Carlson back to back so Magnus he
will feel their breath on his neck as we
reach the final stages of this Sprint to
the Finishing Line uh players on 13
points Anish giri Daniel dubov ortemiev
and the like they still have a chance
but they are hoping for results to go
their way elsewhere here we see the rest
of the top 20. it's really closed the
field now it's really closed up with
only two points separating 20th Place
and first place so let's go to those
matchups Lawrence it is who did draw
against Nakamura against Magnus Carlson
yeah uh potential banana skin again for
Magnus shimanov showing some great form
uh in the blitz so Carlson is gonna have
to be on his a game to deal with that
Marta rosian against Serana a battle of
the youngsters can go either way came up
with white against Nakamura the super
solid Vincent Kamer a draw is not
sufficient for Hikaru Nakamura he has to
go for it here absolutely has to go for
it as does yandrist of Duda also on 13
and a half points playing Black against
andrakin it's uh Do or Die situation now
for a lot of these players
yeah and uh I did see that uh many of
you are asking why there are such
mismatches in terms of the points that's
because it's a long tournament everyone
has played each other already there at
the top so we do see opportunities for
players like shiman of one and a half
points off Magnus Carlson uh to LEAP up
and get that up float and uh still
causes for many of them to be confident
with two rounds to go let's go to the
standings of the women's tournament
where Lawrence you mentioned it is
crunch time this is the climax of the
tournament the final round everything
will be decided here and now we have
tanzongi the women's rapid Champion up
against the bibisara in that race for
first place they're on the same number
of points they've played each other
already but uh who will win who will
grab that title or will we see a playoff
and uh shrivel over and hampi Canary
half a point back
there's a big gap between fourth place
and fifth place so it does feel like
those top four it's all about them can
they get the win that they need in the
final round and talking of the final
round Lawrence the matchups humpy canero
attack against tanzong Yi what a clash
that's gonna be harika as well against
asua bayeva two Indians with the role of
spoiler
absolutely yeah
um it's uh uh it's a great final round
here
um if you're a survive you can be
quietly confident I think because uh
humpicanura with the white piece is very
very difficult to beat Zhang zhongji has
played phenomenal chess across both
events but if you're asking wherever
you're thinking okay I'll be with white
solid she could even win this game and
I've got black against harika who's a
point and a half offshore harika again
quality player
this is a chance for us if I ever I feel
and poor shuvalova after being out in
front for so long now her fate is not in
her own hands I feel as though we could
get a repeat Champion there
on screen though we see shimanov
Rising all the way to the top is he
going to play a part in the history of
this tournament and cause a monster
upset
I could soon find out
it's going to be exciting that's for
sure
Magnus Carlson has struggled with the
black pieces today losing two games so
far with black so uh yeah shimanov
suddenly inwards and trusses there we
saw Duda a moment ago now we see Mata
rossian against Serana the Giant Slayer
serrana can he continue his streak he's
got to be feeling super confident as
well yes he has black but Mata rosian
not maybe on paper as strong as karawana
uh sorry as Carlton and Nakamura so
but it's that's a fear he's won a five
in a row Serrano he's got ten and a half
out of his last 11 games Lawrence what a
run that is 10 and a half out of 11
serrana and uh here we see artemias at
the publishing all Russian clash as both
Players Point behind aiming to catch up
uh we are ready almost we're just
awaiting just awaiting Magnus Carlson
and there we go handshake
can he hold off the chasing pack can he
hold on to his lead shimanov we saw
bailed out with the draw against
Nakamura he's had a few quick draws in
the tournament very solid player I
should mention from Russia maybe not too
familiar to some of our viewers shimanov
has been a 2600 Grand Master for many a
year already and he most mostly work
Works nowadays as a chess coach and a
chess commentator as far as I'm aware
coaching Russian youth teams Russian
teams over there and uh yeah very good
chess understanding if slightly
unorthodox playing style he played a
very odd variation of the Scandinavian
against Nakamura will he play something
to surprise Magnus Carlson here
uh we're awaiting the first move what do
you think does Magnus look composed to
me he looks a bit touchy a bit nervous
yeah he does look touchy to me as well
let's see
French defense
which variation will white shoes Magnus
has employed the French a lot he's
beaten the likes of Anish giri in the
tournament using this opening but he's
ridden his luck slightly some uh dodgy
positions here we see H6 a very trendy
move of early Pawn Sacrifice by Magnus
Carlson he brings his Queen out then
Retreats change your mind but black has
grabbed the bishop pair in the process
very healthy solid position for white I
said it was a pawn sacrifice white could
have grabbed the pawn on D5 that has
been very well analyzed in recent
opening books opening courses online and
now black sets up a solid wall of Pawns
in the center it's a closed position
which you would think favors Magnus
Carlson so now he has survived the
opening can he work his magic a bit
later on
what do you think Lawrence black super
solid but white with more Central space
yeah
um
reminds me of actually some lines of the
Trump that I used to play with an early
Bishop G5 where you give up the thoughts
yeah of the Trump obviously where you
give up the dark Square Bishop
always found that you've don't get very
much here with the way it looks is okay
like you've got the center
but actually you haven't got much to
bite on here and uh Magnus with the
bishop pair I'm not saying it's terribly
bad for white but I think there isn't
really too many effective plans in this
position
yeah it does feel like uh shimanov here
is playing very timidly he's showing a
lot of respect to Magnus he didn't
really want uh the wall of Pawns he had
in the center he didn't want that space
Advantage instead he's transitioned into
a position where it is symmetrical but
remember Magnus he plays this type of
opening with white and with black uh he
also defeated matarosian in the first
game of the of the day Magnus on the
white side of this type of Pawn
structure
here we're seeing shimanov cynically
trying to trade off all the pieces now
it's opposite color Bishops I'm
surprised Magnus allowed this I've got
to say uh Magnus had more ambitious
options at his disposal but now it just
looks very equal feels like shimanov
playing for the draw will he be punished
if anyone you would take black just
because uh black is slightly ahead in
development now Black's Queen is out
Black's got a nice Pawn structure he's
gonna put his King on the G7 Square nice
hiding place for it there we go and yeah
this is looking very balanced you would
expect all of the Rooks to come off the
board
neither side in any danger here any time
trouble
Magnus needs some magic I think he
realizes he's not in his best shape and
he just wants to stem the bleeding he
wants to not lose yet again with black
and uh this one looking very balanced
will this open the door to Hikaru
Nakamura Lawrence
he could be should be looking at another
game this one I think this is so
exciting
yeah let's go to Hikaru that's a king's
Indian
let's go straight there
playing Black again since it came or
going for it and rightly so
we can see two on the board
this is a fantastic opening Choice by
Hikaru Nakamura it was his childhood uh
pet line he used to play this opening
all the time as a kid Hikaru with some
amazing victories one of the world's
leading experts in this opening and it's
really unbalanced just like we showed a
moment ago Lawrence neponishi against
grushook it ends up in a really chaotic
mess and Vincent's a very classical
player Hikaru very Universal very
flexible
I like how uh Nakamura has handled the
opening as well white does have this
kind of avalanche reports pushing
forward on the queen side but it's not
clear what to do next let's see if we
can get cameras on them as well in a
moment black does release the tension in
the center
I've seen Vladimir kramnik win this
position many times with white but not
many players can match kramnik's
understanding so
how will Vincent react that's nice
getting active
Nakamura he will have half an eye on the
Magnus result if Magnus does draw if he
sees them get up quickly then Nakamura
will know he needs to step up the gears
needs to take more risks I think if Naka
doesn't win this game Magnus will cruise
to the gold
[Music]
on this position
well I think it's the sort of position
Hikaru wants basically very unbalanced
uh hikaru's got play in the center on
the king side obviously Vincent has got
space on the queen side objectively I
would say that this is you know
obviously fine some kind of dynamic
balance but precisely the position that
Hikaru Nakamura needs uh in this
particular tournament situation so the
moves coming in
um
a bit more slowly
we can see an update here
yeah and we see
sorry carry on alerts
no I was I was going to say Rook A3
typical idea in these structures
um to float The Rook over on the third
rank but
please do say ah there we can see uh
camera
shot of them both
yeah uh crucial game for them still a
very balanced position meanwhile the
Magnus custom game is changing slightly
uh it has changed horn structure Brooks
are off the board
learn something
yeah maybe yeah maybe we can go to the
women's tournament uh Lawrence because
it is the final round over there medals
are on the line we will of course update
you with how Carson is doing Nakamura uh
but tanzong Yi up against humpy canero
on top board uh we do also don't be
winning humpy just winning she's just
got more pieces
she's got two Rooks and a bishop
for a queen that should be way too much
but don't underestimate a queen in Blitz
Lawrence I've been there too many times
objectively white is winning that's too
much material but Black's Queen watch
out for it getting active the white king
not entirely safe on the background
either
tanzogi has jumped in with her Knight to
D3 this is snapped off by humpy and yeah
still looks pretty good for white to me
I don't think a capture of either of
those two pieces Black's Queen can take
the White Knight you can play e takes D3
take the bishop as well I don't think
either of them really cuts the mustard
neither of them really does the business
white Bishop can just Retreat now defend
the Rook Henry stuff breaking breaking
news breaking news Bibi Sarah ASAP has
got a winning position against
harika she takes the bridge one F3 it is
forced mate if she avoids these checks
it's gonna be over and given the
situation on the other board that will
mean that baby Sarah is going to retain
her title
and it's uh just um
she's completely winning she's found a
safe Square for her King her King is
getting checked but it's going to come
round to the G5 square safe haven I
don't think uh the checks will continue
for that much longer you've got two or
three checks his white and then it's
game over
wow as soon as you move your king uh
here for harika that spells disaster if
you don't have checks Black's night is
Just Gonna decide the game she can
already start bringing her Knight in
threatening Checkmate there we go
bibrasara landing the Knight on E1 Queen
G2 Checkmate monster threat
wins remember tanzongi has to win
herself but she's up against it she's
losing to humpy canero could humpy do a
favor now to uh ubisara wow and we see a
resignation white gets checked the King
was about to get forked this uh yeah
this Knight check on F3 was decisive so
a bit sorry I saw about ever about to
win a gold medal we think unless black
wins in this game but looks like white
is just doing the business Checkmate
incoming
crashing two defeats there's no chance
black wins this game white Rook whites
two Rooks and Bishop combine two nicely
Lawrence this by the way to put things
into like so put things in sorry to put
things into perspective baby Sarah has
to go over one her last five games in a
row that's how far behind she was she
might only win it by half a point but
she won her last five games in a row and
tangible she is dead lost there's
nothing she can do look at this position
it's just totally over she's she's
getting mated I mean it it doesn't
really matter where she goes with the
queen
um I'm picking her way too strong gonna
find a way to convert this and and
that's going to be that there's going to
be no playoff nothing because
shovel over just lost her footing over
the past few rounds
maybe Sarah she's going to be the Local
Hero it's gonna be absolute pandemonium
in the stadium
and that's it she's going to win rookie
four and that's going to force
resignation
wow
yeah that confirms the world title going
to Kazakhstan the home nation they will
be dancing in the streets Lawrence
tanzong Yi heartbreak for her as she
aims for a second world Crown but Magnus
Carlson
excuse me Magnus Carlson has magic
another position
somehow around here
wow it took Lawrence we'll go through
that in a moment but there's still games
going on okay we can see here which game
is this is this hike Mata rosian uh
can't see the player's faces right now
just judging by them I recognize the
hands materosian White against Serana
with black Giant Slayer Serana looks
like he's in trouble white has an extra
Pawn but this should be a draw with best
play Brooks will balance each other out
put the pressure on Magnus Carson and
win this game if not Carlson might be
clear by a whole point oh look at this
point
okay I'm being told Hikaru has won so he
keeps up the chase it's going to be very
tense that final round
how can black stop Checkmate rookie 8
mate is coming
are the check's gonna dry up White's
King can hide surely white skin can
advance to safety
and you have to block the background
Checkmate rookie eight mate will trap
the black king
okay this Pawn is coming this must be
winning surely for white Lawrence
rookie eight two two but he's been
deflected away
wow one one that's a move with panic
suddenly oh he's blundered his Rook he's
playing
and look at the concentration on
serana's face on his hands even
um
wow
devastating for Serana look at that
tears in his eyes
oh that's a tough one that hurts oh I
can feel his pain from here Alex say
Serana had it in his hands
at least it looked like he was holding
to lose there is a massive blow we can
see some lights here Yep this is about
to be a draw between Michael kobalia and
Christopher you not a great result for
either player as they aim for the prizes
but uh yeah such slim margins to run a
blundering in a dead wrong position here
we see some analysis I believe this is
magzulu and uh he was up against uh from
Armenia
um so this game it looks like it's ended
maybe in a draw but uh yeah not at the
top of the table either of these two
players Serana he was on a great run as
said by aft chess in the featured chat
it's a great run but unfortunately he
hit a stumbling block matarosian
wow and we'll see the Fallout we'll see
the repercussions of all of those
results in a moment but Lawrence yeah as
we see the playing hole there final
thoughts on the last round of the
women's tournament and the penultimate
round of the open
well I think you know it's uh it it it's
it shows just how much
uh momentum plays a part in this
tournament
maybe Sarah was not even in the mix
until a couple of rounds out
we weren't even talking about her uh we
were saying shuvalova gunina tanjong ji
they were all the big names who we
thought could win it and all of a sudden
maybe Sarah racks up four three four
five wins in a row and just like that
she doesn't even need to play a playoff
she becomes
the first woman that I can remember in a
long time to retain the world Blitz
title she's a she's a blitz Phenom
you've got to give it to her what a
final result final round result beating
a very strong harika commiserations to
shovel over who doesn't even get the
silver medal because humpy kanura beats
tanjongi to leapfrocker it goes
asavoyeva kunero and then shivalova and
tanjongji in a tie for third and fourth
will get know who gets the third and
fourth there
I would love to see the scenes in the
playing Hall she's the Local Hero
playing in Kazakhstan
um congratulations to her
Lawrence 18 years old and she's won two
World titles already yeah this title is
back to back so congratulations to all
fans out there in Kazakhstan and to
bibra
Meanwhile we do have a game still
ongoing a Time scramble uh which board
is this this is one of the lower Boards
of the open section and it looks like
Rook vs Bishop that famous end game this
one I think should be a draw but you
have to be mightily careful as white not
to drop your Bishop not to get
checkmated
um while so much action look at this the
white king in the corner now and this is
a well-known drawing Motif okay he
didn't put the king in the corner I'm
slightly surprised by that normally the
idea is to put the king in the opposite
color corner to your Bishop because then
there's a bunch of stalemating ideas
there's no way to actually win the
opponent's piece so uh does look like a
bit of Nerfs both players living on the
increments
ah fighting it out till The Bitter End
and I love to see this despite the fact
it's one of the lower boards in the open
section
not that much to play for apart from
rating points and pride but they're
still fighting desperately and now white
needs to put his King in the corner
there we go aiming for stalemate
now the black Rook can go and attack
that white Bishop it would have been a
check however black played that with
just a few seconds left
this one should be a draw white can put
the bishop next to the king I think he's
gonna play it
stalemate
is threatened and yeah this one will
eventually surely be a draw but Black's
gonna try forever he's gonna hope for a
blunder by a white
yeah we'll let them play that out we're
gonna go for a break when we come back
it will be the final round of the open
of this year's World let's chess
championships it's nicely poised we do
have a clear leader it's your man Magnus
Carlson but
is the uh
world champion the world rapper Champion
going to uh to force it home or are the
chess Gods going to smile upon Hikaru
Nakamura or yeah
both half a point behind Magnus Carlson
to also play for
we'll be back in just a couple of
minutes final round coming up just now
[Music]
so I first learned about ill Cafe
through my buddy Aaron he was like Hey
me and a group of fellas meet at this
Cafe downtown on Sundays and we play
chess there it'd be really cool if you
could stop by and hang out with us and
you know just feel the vibe and so I
showed up
and it was a nice bike I was like yo ill
Cafe is pretty ill
[Music]
here man
[Music]
don't do it
[Music]
what's up
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
thank you
foreign
[Music]
championships is upon us
we've got an unbelievably exciting round
to uh behold before we talk about the
open section
of course here with David Howe David
we've just witnessed
the local hero baby Sarah asawayeva from
nowhere she wasn't even in the picture a
few rounds ago
she has come storming through Galloping
through like like a horse you know you
watch the Grand National and they come
Galloping through at the Finish Line
she's won by a neck
amazingly winning her last five games
and then beating harika in the final
game to clinch the title and to retain
her title at the tender age of 18 quite
astonishing
yeah it's incredible congratulations
many congratulations to bibisara by Eva
it is like a fairy tale as you say Loris
to overtake all of those Leaders with
that last kind of winning streak uh it's
just fantastic to see and hopefully it
does inspire generations of Kazakhstan
players they wanted to host this
tournament for a reason and they have
been rewarded with a gold medal in the
world women's Blitz and a silver medal
in the uh women's rapid tournament so
fantastic organization of the tournament
over there in Kazakhstan and they really
do deserve those medals many
congratulations but Lawrence there is a
lot upcoming it is Magnus Carlson in the
lead of the open section we can't forget
that Nakamura is on his Tails as well
and Jan Christoph Duda half a point
behind Magnus Carlson will check out the
match up soon but
um some major clashes ahead also
the fourth player in with a Chance of
gold but he will rely on favors in other
results so we've seen the inspirational
run of ASU bayeva who is going to take
the Open Championship that world title
Lawrence predictions for the final round
is Carlson gonna do it or is Nakamura
gonna force a playoff or maybe even
leapfro Carlson
well in my experience when things are in
Magnus Carlson's hands when Destiny in
his is in his hands he tends to pull
through I think he's going to gather
himself
uh and he's going to finish the job here
White against Abdul sirov not the
easiest pairing in the world obviously
for Magnus none of the pairings are at
this stage
but you've got to think that all the
chips have fallen in Magnus Carlson's
favor today
he has been lost he's been worse and
nonetheless nobody
has managed to capitalize in those spots
yes he did lose against Serana
um but even when he lost to Serana that
round
Nakamura also lost at the same time and
it's really been a case of Hikaru
Nakamura not being able to reproduce the
form he had on day one he hasn't been
able to push his his foot down at the
required times
um so now he finds in his self now he
finds himself in a situation where he's
having to pray that Magnus simply does
not win you never want to be in that
spot I think Magnus is going to do it
this title means the world to him he
will be world champion across all
formats
um
yeah
um you're right he uh has all those
titles Nakamura has the Fisher random
World title I've got to say but uh we
are being told that the final standings
breaking news final standings of the
Women's flits World Championship has
been delayed because we're being told
that kostenyuk is launching an appeal
we're not sure what the appeal is about
we're not sure it's about uh her results
her games either way I don't think it
affects the final standings it doesn't
really affect the uh win of the gold
medal of the title by assurable but
possible controversy we could see a
shake-up in those standings if fide
uphold the appeal meanwhile a moment ago
we did see the matchups for the final
round Magnus Carlson does start as the
favorite to win the goals however the
pairings the matchups are not
necessarily in his favor here we see
Duda aiming to win aiming to strike
against the heartbroken Serana after his
defeat in the previous round we see
Abdul satorov make his way all up to
board one
he's been nowhere I've got to say
throughout the blitz tournament he
hasn't hit his usual high standards uh
nor the back up to satorov but he has a
chance to change the fate of the
tournament and remember he has beaten
Magnus Carlson before last year in the
world rapid in Poland so uh it's not
going to be easy for Magnus Nakamura
meanwhile has a on paper favorable
pairing against pentala Hare Krishna
Hare Krishna a strong player but not
necessarily known for his Blitz skills
here we see mati rosian the fourth of
that group uh he is up against karawana
matarasian has to win and also has to
hope that none of the three players
above him win including a Magnus defeat
that is what the young Armenian has to
hope for Fabi of course aiming to spoil
that dream and yeah we are waiting as
per usual for Magnus Carlson to arrive
there we go he's at the board at the
table looking very focused he has the
white pieces he did beat Noddy back a
couple of days ago in the world rapid
will he do it again Destiny in his own
hands you may mentioned at Lawrence
another I think sixth word Blitz title
within his grasp a win and he's got it
he secured it but a draw and we might
see a playoff that would be cool too
seeing a playoff between Magnus Carls
and anti Cara Nakamura maybe with Duda
in the mix there somewhere uh but what
will we see we'll find out shortly
we are awaiting the gong and the action
beginning
predictions in terms of opening Lawrence
will Magnus play it safe or will he go
all out
we'll soon see he's played one e45 so
we're going to get something relatively
quiet you tend to feel yeah Spanish and
I don't know whether Magnus is going to
just play a line which is very drawish
now he plays D3 this is a clever
move just trying to get a position of
sorts uh keep keep the game alive quick
A4
and
this has all been played
many times before
these structures are discussed for
hundreds of years
yep we should mention that this uh yeah
this theory is constantly evolving with
small nuances here and there small
little ideas which I'm sure Abdus is
aware of however Magnus does have a bit
more experience with white and black on
the side uh of this structure so Magnus
will know everything pretty much there
is to note Under the Sun in this type of
opening can nodderbeck kind of match the
speed he's already lagging slightly
Below on the clock it is the Spanish
opening it is the Royal repairs but a
slightly unorthodox move order to start
this game I've got to say Magnus showing
a sign of nerves there he pretty much
adjusted the piece and he said sorry as
He adjusted it normally you should be
saying or just before you touch a piece
it's strange there we saw that during
last year's World Championship is Bishop
meanwhile is kicked back to A2 and
nodderbeck allowing an opening of the
center uh nordebec pushing his pawns on
the queen side Magnus trying to open the
center of the board who will this favor
the stakes get higher in these types of
positions once the pawns start to
disappear once the pieces can actually
start playing and traditionally as soon
as white achieves this break it tends to
be a little bit of pressure black tends
to be the one who has the burden of
equalizing things so I think from a
objective point of view still balanced
of course but Magnus Carlsen can't be
too unhappy he can play it safe later if
he needs to I like the fact that he's
kept the tension he'll keep an eye on
the other results and I'm sure we'll do
that too right Lawrence we will update
everyone as the other results come in
Nakamura aiming desperately to win and
yank yourself do that let's not forget
him in with a shout as well and uh okay
the center has locked up white has more
space Lawrence who does this favor
well I think it's still uh ever so you
know
balanced really but I'm not sure why
does now block the center
um
not entirely sure who's better here um
not an easy position to play
not 85. I like this move though
mm-hmm
like locks that Queen side down so
Black's Knights actually they are
dancing into the white position there's
a threat of Knight into D3 I'm not sure
which Knight but one of those two
knights is headed towards D3 Magnus
needs to guard against that but long
term that Black Knight on B4 doesn't
have too many Escape squares so Magnus
might try might try to surround that
piece later to Corrales and yeah it's
it's certainly a double-edged position I
said Magnus didn't want to take any
risks until he knew what was going on
but by closing the center he pretty much
said okay this one is not going to be a
draw this one's not going to be boring
we see his expression there Magnus
Carson
learning time on the clock for the first
real moment in the game
and uh Abdul satorov looking very
confident he's two points behind so of
course he's playing for significant
financial prizes but he won't win a
medal in this tournament Abdul satoroff
at the stakes are lower for him but it's
always fun to relax a bit and uh you
know that you're trying to spoil your
opponent's tournament it takes some of
the pressure off often psychologically
and that gives you an edge Magnus now
Lawrence thinking for almost one minute
this is incredible
I was gonna say what what what's what's
causing the pause here he does go for
Knight F1 to prevent Knight D3
I wonder what he was spending his time
on there
yeah it's it's hard to tell maybe it's
nerves just slowing the hand somewhat
black brings the bishop out very
aggressive move pinning white tonight ah
on F3
but this was probably it because
yeah because Bishop takes F3 sorry
Bishop takes F3 and Knight C2
is in the position here I think this is
what Magnus was spending his time on
trying to work out what to do against
this movement Magnus now getting
decently behind on time here this is
worrying
yeah to say the least and okay I think
he brings his Knight out to E3 attacking
that black Bishop White Knight on the E3
Square also keeps an eye on that night
Fork you mentioned you highlighted with
nicely to their Lawrence uh so black has
retreated but Abdul satoroph like you
said he's piling on the pressure he's
creating threats and that has caused
Magnus to slow down
a lot uh I don't really like what Magnus
has done with his pieces either it looks
very very clumsy but still under control
for now under a minute can Abdu sotorov
continue the momentum keep creating
threats maybe bring Black's Rooks into
the action if not then Magnus will have
a respite he will have time to
consolidate
this one is one of the most tense
positions you could imagine so kg only a
trade of two sets of Pawns so far what
does Abdus reach forward to do it looks
like he's
traded off a night now on F3 I'm
surprised I paused there because yeah
this looks counter-intuitive exchanging
pieces
especially when that pin looks so
uncomfortable for white Lawrence he's
got this tactical idea in mind of
trading off everything Knight C2
deflecting white tonight here the white
light Square Bishop
what about this transition who does it
favor it looks like white tonight's
coming into F5 surely that's dangerous
dangerous
[Music]
position does the position
position does look dangerous here Rook
D1 on the board
the queen on D4 very very exposed
and he brings the queen back to C5 but
this allows Knight F5 and Magnus now
clearly uh in a better spot he's
unraveled
Magnus Carlsen
so close yet again he can taste it
it's got to be precise like Bishop G5
looks a little loose but it's okay H4
okay Bishop 25 H4
great move by Magnus Carlson gaining
time hitting the black bishop and now
White's King never ever has to worry
about background checkmates I think this
black Bishop has to go back so a lot of
time for Abdul sotorov he's helped
Magnus with that slip with his putting
his Bishop on the wrong square and now
it feels like there are some tactics in
the air I'm looking at somehow trying to
attack that black queen which doesn't
have too many safe squares we've got to
say okay Brooks hitting that black queen
as soon as you kick her away kick away
Black's most active pieces then you can
start to for example capture that Black
Knight with your bishop or maybe even
harass that black knight push the pawn
to G3 wow that's take on A5
black queen is eyed up by White's Bishop
surely there's a tactic here Lawrence
somewhere Black's position is falling
apart it's so loose
Knight takes D5 desperation Abdus
surely this move doesn't work what is
this he wants to go E4
small update Lawrence small update I'm
being told that Duda is significantly
better in his game he could win and uh
try to catch up with Magnus Nakamura is
worse he's significantly worse in his
position so uh yeah these results are
going to dictate the fate of the world
title meanwhile the white Rooks
harassing this black queen
Lawrence where's this black queen going
five seconds
this is just oh this is a bloodbath this
should be a win now for Magnus Carson
three seconds to have two story made
that move with one second left all
Magnus needs to do now is consolidate
protect all his pieces curl up into a
ball and ensure there are no last minute
tricks white has an extra night that
will decide the game and I'll do some
tour of down to one second for the third
move in a row walking into a fork but
Magnus has seen it all grabbing two
pawns and a handshake it's confirmed
Magnus Carlson gets the double he wins
the world Blitz Championship Lawrence
wow Magnus Carlson I said it before the
round when the Fate is in his hands
what a spot with white in the last round
he tends not to fail Magnus Carlsen
triple world champion classical rapid
and Blitz
it wasn't smooth sailing it had its
moments but the field yet again not able
to really put him under enough pressure
when he's down he had a a string of very
very fortunate events
the game that he lost the game that he
should have lost all the results went
his way and I think kaisa was smiling
down on Magnus from the start of today
she selected her winner
Magnus Carlsen once again World Blitz
champion
and
we saw the smile on his face the joy the
relief after such a tough tournament
such a marathon endurance event and here
we do see Mata rosian trying to keep up
uh trying to potentially fight for a
medal by taking down carowana looks like
White's position is beautiful right now
some pressure look at those white rocks
stacked up oh sorry this is against Duda
not marijuana
um
yes oh this is dudas to run it oh pardon
me this is not uh martial this is due to
surrounded so Duda if he wins I think
might well get this silver medal
and uh is HE capable it does look very
nice for white right now that is Young
Kristoff Duda uh we see
Serana with the black pieces Queens are
off the board though Lawrence and maybe
this brings some salvation for black
like it's rock solid despite being less
active and do just having to start
retreating
suddenly the advantage is all gone
white is no longer better and we do also
know that Nakamura fighting Duda needs
to win if he wants a medal
absolutely yeah very solid
yeah
it's hard to imagine uh White winning
this anymore Lawrence
can't can't see a white wind here ever
if anything you take black in this
position because black has got the open
B Farm
um
and so well
a small update Lawrence Nakamura is in a
dead drawn end game now against Hare
Krishna he survived the worst Nakamura
but he's unlikely to win Byron a miracle
so Nakamura might draw
if he draws and do the draws too it will
come down to tie breaks to decide the uh
the destination of those medals
Duda against Serana can he grind it out
squeeze water out of a stone in this
opposite colored Bishop end game should
be a draw
what are you expecting from these last
two crunch results on the top few boards
well it's just about who's gonna get the
silver and bronze medals now and this
game kind of dictates all of that
and I think dude has blown it Laura
Serana could play the role of spoiler
yes again look at those black Rooks
lined up against the B2 Square I think
the black is breaking through crushing
it and surely now Duda is toast he's on
the ropes how is he gonna survive we see
an updated position black has won
everything black is won the white pawns
on the king side black is one the B2
Pawn
I think Duda is going down no medals
going to Poland in this tournament
unless he can pull out a miracle safe
look at that black apron it's going to
team up with the black rook and Bishop
and this is almost game over now Black's
King just can enter
white is totally stuck totally paralyzed
just has to wait
and do that playing on one or two
seconds every move oh two seconds left
there Black's King is inevitably making
its way over and this is fatal now
discover check hitting the white Bishop
there we go
Bishop Falls Duda leans back in his
chair almost falls off his chair and
resigns
and that's a massive massive loss for
yanchish Stuff doodle because with that
loss
uh suddenly Serana
uh overtakes
yeah yeah sorry I've got to say as well
look at Nakamura he's peering over his
shoulder he was checking out that result
shaking his head he's now in his head
trying to try and do a maths equation
he's trying to work out whether he
guarantees the silver medal with a draw
because he's almost guaranteed to draw
at this point I'm not sure if we can
zoom in slightly but it's Rooker Knight
against Rook a well-known theoretical
draw harakrishna an endgame expert will
never lose that one so you're right
Lawrence uh judah's chances look like
they've gone Serana overtaking but
Nakamura is he secured the silver with a
draw it looks like the current position
uh they're playing very very fast but uh
yeah simply no way to win the same game
if your opponent knows the technique
all you need to do is pin the White
Knight pin the White Knight check the
white king when it pokes its head out
from the shelter there
and I think a draw is in the works it's
gonna happen barring a uh maybe a uh
blunder by Hare Krishna or a loss on
time Murado he knows every trick in the
book he'll keep pressing the wind would
guarantee him the silver medal and a
huge check but of course disappointing
he couldn't clinch the gold after going
into today with a one-point lead Harry
Krishna look at him
such a great student of the game he
studies so hard on these end games
and he's not going to lose this Lawrence
I don't think so but Hikaru gonna try
until he can try no longer
yeah and the Arbiters won't step in with
the 50 move rule which marks no progress
no Pawn pushes or captures they won't
step in the Arbiters they're only
allowed to after 75 moves without any
action so until Hare Krishna claims that
draw I think Nakamura will keep trying
keep selling the traps he's relocating
his Knight now as we see with some
checks Black's King's still not on the
edge of the board you can't trap it
can't track mate look at nakamura's face
he is disappointed visibly he knows that
uh this day could have gone so much
better
he just couldn't get Motoring in the
early stages maybe Nakamura will regret
those two very quick draws in the first
two games of the day
yep I agree I think he took way too
quick draws
um but to potentially not even get
silver after being a point clear on the
final day he's going to be gutted how
many more chances is he gonna get in
this tournament this was his year Point
Clear
you know played beautiful chess in day
one
he just wasn't able to keep his nerve in
the home stretch
yeah and I'm looking at the tie brick
scores I think Nakamura should clinch
Silva ahead of matarosian if he draws
but he's not aware of that he isn't
going to be 100 sure Mata rosian did
beat Carolina so many congrats to him
the young Armenian Phenom and uh I think
he's got a share of second price no
matter what now
uh Mata rosian as long as Nakamura
doesn't win at least and with the shake
of the head Nakamura this is typical for
any viewers of his twitch Channel
whenever he looks away like this shaking
his head he knows what is happening he
knows that a draw is inevitable now he's
just playing on
out of frustration uh out of
disappointment and shared second prize
and Nakamura
in the end still very healthy
financially but no world title No Gold
Medal Lawrence he's going to get it one
day surely
well I don't know I don't know I think
if you know this this might have been
the year where
you know you really thought it could
happen
uh
it's it's it's a shame for the [ __ ]
fans
uh you know he's just playing on I'm
sure uh pure emotion now Hikaru
he's uh
gutted he's thinking about previous
games where did it go wrong
what could I have done better
and
yeah just as this game reaches its
closing stages Nakamura frustrated her
draw inevitable now I just want to shout
out everyone still watching today I know
there's tens of thousands of you so I
want to say hi and thank you so much for
sticking with us as the drummer has
unfolded of course we see the
destination of the titles they have been
uh finalized now pretty much but yeah we
will bring you confirmation of uh
shortly ackerman's had a great
tournament we've got to say uh rightly
should be proud of himself but
uh unfortunately it's not going to end
on the note he wanted and I think at
this point Hare Krishna can safely claim
the 50 move rule he's defended this long
enough he's defend it very accurately
very well but uh yeah there we go the
Arbiter steps in no progress has been
made and we do have a draw Nakamura
confirms that he ends in joint second
place
wow
absolutely
incredible scenes
Magnus Carlson
the Norwegian God
proving he is Untouchable World rapid
Champion World Blitz champion
World classical
Champion congratulations to him
regardless of how he did it he managed
to do it and that's what the greatest
players do they find a way
when their backs are against the wall
When the tide has turned when things are
looking rough they still managed to find
a way once again congratulations to Baby
Sarah asubai Eva for that stunning
comeback
to win the World Blitz championship and
retainer title Magnus has been rapid and
Blitz Champion jeweled wrapped in blue
Champion both in 2014 and 2019 now once
again in 2022
devastated look of Hikaru Nakamura he
wanted this so bad he had a lackluster
rapid event the blitz event was supposed
to be his he had an amazing day one
point clear going into day two he just
couldn't get the the the balls rolling
he couldn't get the fire and the energy
the levels required to compete with
somebody like Magnus Carlson
uh David uh uh just emotions running
wild
uh who was uh
uh who's really impressed you this
tournament outside of Magnus or bibisara
which names are we going to be looking
at in the future and what are your
general impressions of of this uh
fantastic past five days
yeah first of all I want to say thanks
to everyone watching it has been
fantastic as you say Lawrence the last
five days this is always a great way to
end the year not just for the
professional players out there in
Kazakhstan but for chess fans like
ourselves uh to see to see such a
spectacle as the pieces are already
being cleared away uh but yeah the names
that have impressed me I want to say
hike MATA rosian in the blitz just
phenomenal never let his head drop even
after he lost the Magnus Carson and
Hikaru Nakamura also Vincent climber uh
doing extremely well some of the younger
players like Dennis lazovic
um just extremely impressive they'll
their time will come Magnus won't go on
forever these youngsters will have a go
and they will be able to snatch that
title away someday but uh yeah it was
those of veterans that asserted their
control in the end in the open section
like you said in the women's section
pulling through but
also extremely impressive until tailing
off at the end so much to hope for for
the future from these youngsters and I
mean I'm already looking forward to the
end of next year this world rapid and
Blitz again it's uh it's always a
highlight and
um yeah I can't wait to go in more
detail once the uh once the nerves have
gone just uh through all of those games
just to uh learn from them because in
terms of wrapping and Blitz this is the
creme de La Creme and uh they train on
these time controls they play these time
controls day in day out online chess.com
and uh yeah clearly that pays off so
yeah for Rapid Blitz it's uh there's
Beauty in speechers in itself and or
else it's been a pleasure covering it
with you of course yeah it's been a
pleasure covering it with you of course
David I want to say personal thanks to
you for being such a class act as always
to the rest of the team Walter uh for
being brilliant Benjamin Goran and
everybody else are in the chess.com uh
team who perhaps aren't visible to you
guys but without them none of this would
be possible congratulations Magnus
congratulations bibisara do also bear in
mind that the
2023 Pan-American Intercollegiate team
chess championships are taking place
January 15th Seattle Washington
go.chess.com pan AMS 2023 for more
information on that
well I think we've said it all pretty
much
the chest Cults have smiled once again
upon some of the best names in the
business Magnus Carlsen is still showing
he is the man to be beaten in this sport
he may be relinquishing his classical
World Championship but he will the world
rapid and Blitz Champion for at least
another year congratulations to bibisara
azerbayeva and tanjongji for their
respective victories in the uh Women's
World Blitz and World rapid
uh shout out of course to all of those
competitors who fought so hard
commiserations to the likes of Hikaru
Nakamura Elena shuvalova and those who
came so close
you'll have to come back and fight again
another time it's been an absolute
pleasure thank you to all of you who
have watched over 30 000 of you tuning
in live today your messages of support
are greatly appreciated make sure of
course to keep an eye out for all the
forthcoming events also on chess.com in
2023 we've got plenty on the way it's
going to be a pact year and if judging
by the end of this year we're just gonna
have more drama more action
and plenty
excuse me plenty to celebrate
that's a good way to end the stream
isn't it apologies for that a small
sneeze there
uh I'm Lauren strand I've been with
David Howe uh it's been an absolute
pleasure once again and have a lovely
end of the year celebrate it with your
friends family stay safe stay healthy
we'll see you all in 2023
it's been a pleasure thanks guys
happy holidays everyone bye-bye
life is full of exciting events but it
is our first impressions that we
remember best your first diploma
your first job in a big company
Unforgettable emotions from the first
date the first expensive things you
bought when you got your first paycheck
and your first Investments with freedom
broker Freedom broker look at your
favorite brands from A New Perspective
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]